well it's uh unofficially official
personally I think the DeSantis team
should have waited until tomorrow
because the news came out that they're
going to be doing a special interview
with Elon Musk on Twitter where Rhonda
Sanders will announce he is running for
the presidency now okay that's fine we
got the news the information leaks Elon
Musk confirms he's having a very special
uh interview tomorrow with a big
announcement but then the designers team
put out a video which basically is them
saying they're launching the campaign
saying text launched to this number and
I think that kind of spiked their own
news story but okay fine whatever
it's it's not legal but it's official I
suppose tomorrow will be the the
official legal announcement where then
they're subject to all these laws but as
of today we know for a fact DeSantis
Casey DeSantis just put out a video
basically saying Rhonda Santos is
running for president so here we go
now I want to talk about something else
Target held an emergency meeting and
they're going to be moving all of their
lgbtq materials and sales products to
the back of the store and in a bunch of
locations because they're panicking over
a potential quote Bud Light situation as
parents are concerned because Target is
selling let's just like just binder
materials for children and tucking
bathing suits for kids and things like
that and so uh not too happy about that
so we got that we got a lot of stuff to
talk about plus we could probably talk
about Ukraine and Russia Belgrade before
we get started my friends head over to
castbrew.com and pick up your cast Brew
Coffee look at this delicious and
beautiful Appalachian nights man I
really do love this stuff we we've we
got some really great coffee for you
guys if you want to support the show
support our efforts support our cultural
Endeavors go to casper.com pick up your
cast Brew Coffee we got rise with
Roberto Jr that's the most popular
Appalachian nights is number two or you
can join the cast Brew Coffee Club get
three different bags every single month
delivered right to your door this is our
company we're sponsoring ourselves and
we are building coffee shops the first
one's currently underway a lot of work
to be done it's taking a lot longer than
we thought which is unfortunate but some
people apparently already stopped in
because they found a location so super
cool and uh just give us time to get the
coffee shop up and running but with your
support at casper.com we hopefully can
have dozens if not hundreds of locations
all across the country where people can
come in for a cup of coffee and up on
the TVs on the walls will be Tim cast
IRL louder with Crowder Viva and Barnes
good content expanding culture and
creating hubs in various urban areas so
again casper.com but don't forget to go
to timcast.com
click join us to become a member and
support our work directly you'll get
access to our Discord server and
uncensored members only shows Monday
through Thursday at 10 10 p.m and you
can actually call in and talk to us and
our guests in these members only
uncensored shows if you've been a member
for at least six months or you sign up
at the 25 per month level so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is representative
Warren Davidson it's an honor to join
you all love it
I'm gonna pull that mic up a little bit
but yeah sure so uh who are you we know
that you were in Congress yeah so
Congressman Warren Davidson I'm from
Southwest Ohio the district goes uh the
west side of Cincinnati from the Ohio
River about a third of the way up the
state so I don't have either Cincinnati
or Dayton in the district but kind of
that part of our state uh came into
Congress after John Boehner resigned and
won a special election at that time I
was a manufacturing guy I had a group of
small manufacturing companies uh and
then prior to that I was in in the Army
so I enlisted in the Army out of high
school got sent over to Germany when the
Cold War was going on over there when
the Wall came down
um right on got to go to West Point from
there served in Ranger regiment as an
officer so Army Ranger business guy
basically when I first ran and in
Congress I'm on financial services and
Foreign Affairs and you're a big crypto
guy so that's good probably the most
knowledgeable member of Congress I'd
imagine uh certainly one of them uh
we're we've been working hard to get I
mean I've been trying to get a bill
passed since 2017. uh seems like it
would have really helped a lot a lot of
things could have been averted but um
you know maybe this year will be the
year right on well thanks for hanging
out we got Seamus Coughlin joining us my
name is Seamus Cagle and I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes
where we make animated cartoons and I
just released one today about our friend
Tim Poole over here I think you guys
will like it if you go over there and
watch that it's very enjoyable cartoon
to make I think it's an enjoyable one to
talk watch Tim seemed to enjoy it he
tweeted it out I also have a podcast
called shamer I stream on Tuesdays and
Thursdays at 6 PM Eastern that's over on
Rumble we just streamed today I thought
I had a great conversation with Will
Noland
hey buddy Ian Crossland good to see you
Seamus great to see you man good morning
good to meet you man likewise I'm
invigorated about this talk about crypto
or maybe we can talk about that tonight
because I know we got a lot into it yeah
nutty stuff going on and if you guys
want to follow me Ian cross on
everywhere on social media I'd be happy
to uh get in touch with you there we
also have Mr duprea on my ride yes uh
mr.com I'm enjoying this coffee thanks
for the Revelation nights quite good
yeah I'm a fan so far
um I'm at surge.com everyone the
internet uh ready for the show whenever
you are let's jump into this first story
from timcast.com Casey DeSantis teases
Governor DeSantis presidential campaign
big if true
here's the video they say they call it
Faith because in the face of Darkness
you can see the brighter future let's
just play the video so uh y'all can see
it for yourselves you ready for this
here we go is the audio right make we
got the audio right
[Applause]
Ness you can see that brighter future
a faith that our best days lay ahead of
us
but is it worth the fight
do I have the courage is it worth the
sacrifice
America has been worth it every single
time
text launch to
512345 wait five one two three four five
and that's the video and uh I feel like
this is taking a bit of the wind out of
their sales Casey DeSantis also tweeted
out big if true in reference to this
story from Fox News Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis to announce candidacy for
president Wednesday on Twitter sources
so uh we all knew it was coming and
tomorrow Rhonda santis is supposed or
for those that are listening to us later
later today our Rhonda Santos is going
to be doing an interview with Elon Musk
on Twitter and they're going to uh he's
going to announce he is running for the
present for the presidency so we know he
is now I think putting out this story
and putting out that tweet pulled a lot
of the wind out of their sales I can
understand leaking a little bit like
expectation may happen tune in don't
miss the show but tweeting out that
video basically just announced it and I
feel like that's gonna Elon Musk is
gonna have the interview and then what's
gonna end up happening is there's going
to be a good amount of people maybe 20
20 30 of people who have normally
watched the the Twitter space are going
to be like oh I know already they put
that video out it said text launch we
get it we get it so I don't know what do
you guys think a lot of people are
ranking on them already a lot of the
Trump people uh genuinely are upset
about this I'm gonna say it outright I
think the people who are upset at Rhonda
Sanders are scared of him
uh I do think that this is kind of an
example that he needs a better marketing
team no offense guys if you're listening
right now but I agree you just stomped
on your own fire
um you should have let Elon make the
noise for you so that everyone went back
and watched that Elon interview over and
over again and this is like coming off
the heels a couple weeks ago I think you
Tim on Twitter you had some issues with
his marketing team also
where was that yeah they got they got
Megs I tweeted about jazz Jennings and I
was like why are they so mad yeah but no
I think people will still go to go back
to the Elon Musk interview it's still
going to be a big deal I just think this
pulled a little bit of the wind out of
the sales and us talking about it's
pulling more more wind out of it so that
this okay so I'll tell you right now we
originally the the original title of
this was going to be
um Target emergency meeting they're
pulling back this big boycott Bud Light
we're winning and then it's I'm looking
at the news and it's like they basically
announced also okay well there it is
that's the story the announcement video
was shot from underneath him to make him
look large obviously that's bit
manipulative they should have used some
slow motion with a few cuts to give some
action because it was a very slow boring
video that's just more of an artistic
critique look I think this is the
biggest non-surprise ever I do think a
lot of people are going to watch Elon
musk's uh announcement tomorrow night uh
and look the the race is ultimately
going to be Donald Trump versus uh
Rhonda sanus I think it can be healthy
we just got to stay focused on beating
Democrats uh you know a lot of folks
back home pretty confident Donald
Trump's going to win the primary and
they want to see the competition you
know at some level but they also want to
everybody stay focused on beating
Democrats instead of beating each other
up yeah the other the other aspect of is
I'm very glad Ron's running so as
critical as I'm going to be about the
way that they're announcing I I like
more competition I think we need that we
need more Democrats RFK and Biden we
need to see those guys debating we need
to see Trump and DeSantis debating I'm
very happy about it yeah I mean I love
what DeSantis is doing in Florida part
of what concerns me is just how damaging
it can be to any politician's reputation
to go up against Trump and how good he
is at just ripping these people to
shreds it's one of his Iran very strong
talents yeah and you just wonder if Ron
gets in the ring with Trump is this
going to have lasting damage to his
political brand
yeah I think that's the fear for anybody
I mean particularly you know getting
across ways with Donald Trump hard to
avoid because those are the tactics
Donald Trump uses he goes after the
person he doesn't really go after the
argument and it's worked pretty well for
him I guess the hope for a lot of people
is that he can kind of work his message
in a different way because that's I
think the key to appealing to like
Suburban women convincing people that he
really is going to be able to flip
States uh like Arizona and Wisconsin
again and get the win and you know
people are saying oh well that's the
that's the appeal of DeSantis we think
Trump Maybe Can't Win well the
competition will prove it and
potentially solidify Trump and if it
doesn't hey who knows where we go what
are your feelings like personally
between these guys and just the
Republican party in general like for
president I mean I I haven't endorsed
anybody in the race so far personally I
love both of them uh you know when I
first came to Congress I mean I when you
come in in a special election I came in
in June so it wasn't like everyone else
was coming in I'm like the new kid and
when you come in you you
um have to make a speech and like
literally you go down and you address
from the floor of the house uh all of
your new colleagues and okay it's only
on C-Span but it's kind of a big deal
and so big crowd comes in after you know
take the oath of office and flow through
I make it to the back up where the
freedom caucus and some of the people
that I had gotten to know already were
and this guy comes up to me goes you
know hey I'm Rhonda Santos you're from
Troy Ohio right I go yeah and I didn't
it's like I thought it was neat that he
knew where I was from he goes my wife
Casey's from Troy Ohio so she literally
graduated from the same high school as
my daughter graduated from uh kind of
small world stuff interesting her dad
was the optometrist in the Town Square
so I like the Santa's people I hope that
everything stays friendly I would be
happy if Rhonda Sands was President I
certainly was Happy When Donald Trump
was president and I'm confident he would
do a great job again yeah I'd be happy
if Veronica was President I'd prefer uh
Donald Trump I think Trump's going to go
in get revenge fire a lot of people I
think Rhonda Santos goes in and shakes a
lot of hands I think policy wise Ron is
doing a lot of things that help America
in a lot of ways but I wonder if that's
what we need right now well look one of
the things he did as a governor is I
mean he inspired Governors to be better
than they would have been otherwise in a
lot of states exactly
look yeah well Donald Trump inspired a
lot of Governors to do that and Rhonda
Santa's look oh I would not have had it
backwards yeah yeah Ron DeSantis would
not have won and I think he'll be clear
on that he would not have won without
the support of Donald Trump
but as Governor he did his own thing and
did it really well and I think it's
inspiring he's a pretty young guy he's
younger than me I think at some point
he's got the potential to be president
but just like you said Sheamus hopefully
if he doesn't get derailed right yeah
well and you mentioned that he couldn't
have won without Trump's endorsement
that's certainly true the first time he
won he just barely squeaked past but we
have to acknowledge that his next
Victory after that was an absolute
Landslide I mean he turned Florida from
vague really purple to dark red he
crushed it there I think he's done a lot
of good I definitely hear everyone's
concerns I mean if this was a question
between DeSantis being president and
Trump being president I'm a happy man
right yeah then there's a question of
who's most likely to defeat the
Democrats in a national election
that's tough yeah I see a lot of people
saying that uh I I've look I've seen the
polls the polls are very favorable
favorable for Donald Trump but I've also
talked to people out just in the streets
in the cities and the general
conversation is they groan when it comes
to Donald Trump the moderates and the
independence I mean to say and uh the
sentiment seems to be elected sandus is
a normal guy this is why I think Elon
Musk is doing this interview with him
because Elon Musk said something like I
just want a normal person to be
president or something like that so I
think Elon does want Rhonda Santos to
win yeah whatever that means but what I
was saying before when I said I don't
know if we need that right now in
reference to good policy of course we
always need good policy but I think what
we desperately desperately read
desperate desperately need right now
there we go I got it is a purging of the
corruption well exactly and this is
something that it's important to really
pay attention to which is throughout the
entire Trump presidency his rhetoric and
his tactics and the way he interacted
with the elite was much more criticized
by media than were his policies just as
you mentioned we're will go after people
and not necessarily policies and though
I'm sure you'd agree with me he does go
after policy often as well
the media was almost always attacking
Trump as an individual sometimes they'd
go after his appointments that was
pretty popular sometimes they'd go after
a policy or they'd say we're upset that
he pulled out of the Paris Accord but
often it was the the rhetoric in this
speech was damaging or the way he speaks
about people in the media makes them
feel unsafe or whatever they were
bloviating about and so that's part of
why I think those are the things we
should love about Trump because those
are the things that terrify our enemies
he's called Rosie O'Donnell a fat pig
which is like not a good thing to say
right but
um I think overall and I'm not saying
that there are not valid critiques to
make of Donald Trump's rhetoric but what
I am saying is there were times where he
was so unbelievably on the money in a
way that I have never seen another
politician be capable of right when he
said I'm I'm the president for for
Pittsburgh and not Paris I mean 100
nailed it nailed it you look at the
drain the swamp rhetoric you know what
you're saying Tim look that was a phrase
that look it it sums up if that meant a
lot in 2016 if it meant something in
2022 post Durham report when you look at
this drain the swamp is going to be the
theme you look at Elon Musk I mean he
bought a crime scene the question is
what are we going to do about it that's
a very good way of putting he bought a
crime scene he did all the evidences
there that they were suppressing
information that they were I mean if a
foreign government had done what Twitter
did we'd be calling it an act of War 100
and kudos to Thomas Massey who coined
the they bought a crime scene phrase
okay good for him the problem with
draining the swamp is that I think that
the swap is clogged I don't think I
don't think it can be drained without
some serious uh that's why I'm saying
drumming but he tried last time and he
just he just but it's basically stood
there and looked at it there's a
difference between a first and a second
term and I think Trump underestimated
the swamp and I think he comes into a
second term and he just says there's
nothing I've got the snake there's
nothing holding him back anymore I think
that schedule F story was real yeah I
think I think Rhonda Sanders gets in and
says look guys let's let's shake hands
and figure something out together and
then it's just schedule Edge you think
realistically that because my my fear
and thought is that if any president
went in and they're like all right
schedule F I'm firing all the heads of
all the agencies the alphabets all these
administrators you're fired the CIA
would just have him killed like that and
then no one would get fired that's my
thought you mean like JFK yeah exactly I
don't I don't I don't I don't I don't
think so I think they did that back in
the day but I think you when you look at
Julian Assange you can see their tactics
have changed so when you look at Trump's
first president presidency what do they
do they accuse him of being a Soviet spy
now that now they're trying to accuse
him of rape yeah and so you're seeing
Democrats now using the E Gene Carroll
story as definitive confirmation even
though there's no evidence of anything
it's it's insane so character
assassination is the tactic and then
they're trying to make it illegal for
him to run I mean that's I haven't been
following the story the last couple
weeks but what's been going on in that
venue have you
like since they were well they're
they're they're going after him in New
York for criminal charges which we know
about he's apparently going to be facing
new criminal charges in March of next
year they're already talking about that
Federal level you've got the classified
documents George you've got elected
election interference they're just gonna
throw whatever they can at them they're
going to use every procedural
manipulation to try and stop him I'm not
sure they're going to be able to pull it
off
that's it and then
if something bad happens to Trump I
think this country just implodes if you
look at the hardcore Trump supporter
um you know indicting Trump or
convicting Trump isn't really going to
change their support but if you look at
the people that are already kind of on
the fence you know there's almost no one
that doesn't have an opinion at Donald
Trump I mean he's got 100 Name ID and
99.9 people have a pretty fixed opinion
of them so how does he move those people
and I think they just keep building
negative building negative building
negative and that is the tactic like you
were saying and it's been working you
know and so the question is but you look
in Ohio you know Donald Trump his
message was built for Ohio everything
about it I mean I got to be on Air Force
One ahead of the election with them and
showing stuff uh people did like a
three-hour long tractor parade you know
and he was just blown away it's like who
would think these people like a
billionaire from New York and like they
don't just like you they love you like
no one made this happen it wasn't a
campaign event it was just organic and
that kind of support is still there
amongst the base but the question is
when you go into places like you know
the suburbs you know places like uh
Pennsylvania places like Wisconsin can
you flip Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan
again can you still hold Arizona I mean
that's going to be the decider in this
election
man I'm I I feel like uh oh hey hi good
to see you uh
um I I'm so concerned with votes being
tallied on machines in private with
proprietary software code but but did
you hear Arizona's Banning electronic
voting machines oh based no that's
baseball
yeah they uh they said unless they're
manufactured here in the US and the
source code is public it's got it I'll
free the code yeah I do dude I gave you
a shout out earlier when I was reading
the news and they said they can use them
as long as the source code is public and
it's made in the United States I was
like public Source public code well
there it is now we should we should
actively create one of those and use it
in Arizona instead of just revert yeah
yeah and uh Dominion said that they were
going to be going out of business
because of reputational damage and I'm
like
if you have the option Dominion of
either going out of business or building
your voting machines here in the United
States with open source code why would
you not choose the latter wow just be
like oh I guess we go out of business
especially if you just got a 700 million
dollar plus-up yeah yeah so they didn't
say I guess it was an interview and the
guy didn't say explicitly that's it
we're done for he said based on the
damage we think we're headed towards the
drain that reputational damage is is too
much if they're afraid of the name
recognition they need to change their
name just like uh Blackwater did I think
I think Monsanto got bought by Bayer
because they didn't like the name is
that coming for Bud Light
every every state should do what Arizona
did and say look we don't care about you
want you want out of this one I'll tell
you it's really simple the left is
complaining about the right because you
know Kerry lake is filing his lawsuits
and they say you won't get over 2020 I'm
like all right all right everybody slow
down here's an idea no more foreign
built voting machines
it doesn't even like I don't understand
the argument against it it's like what
we got to spend money to get up upgraded
voting machines for election security
everybody should be in favor of that we
make them here in America that's
American jobs good working class jobs we
do open source codes that people have a
right to see the code why would any
Democrat disagree with that it's a
requirement for all of our defense
Contracting so why wouldn't it be for
our voting system have you looked much
into the blockchain for voting uh
security you know blockchain really
offers a lot of look it's it's immutable
it's distributed Ledger it's a more
secure way it's I mean frankly the most
secure Computing system is truly uh
available with the proof of work kind of
architecture
um but a lot of people don't understand
it uh for one and two uh it really isn't
scalable yet but I think you're going to
start seeing blockchain voting for as
for shares so I think when you can do uh
votes for things like shares that way uh
you will eventually see blockchain as an
immutable record of what happened and
you can audit it it's fully audible
everyone could download a node if you
want to track the election in your state
download the node you see everything all
the code is there it would be a great
way to run an election I want to I want
to just do a hard segue into the the
cultural stories because this this
target news was really big and um I'm
really excited this is a white pill
moment for everybody this is Hope and
optimism Target makes emergency calls
after backlash to quote talk friendly
bathing suits and other Pride products
the company is terrified of a Bud Light
situation a Target Insider told Fox News
the company's lgbtq themed items were
released this month and include tuck
friendly bathing suits chest binders and
packing underwear along with gender
fluid mugs and and other things and I'm
pretty sure this was like for children
is what the big issue was
consumers called for a boycott of Target
over the products taking issue with the
swimwear as well as Pride themed
children's clothing including onesies
t-shirt socks and swim skirts with a tag
rating thoughtfully fit on multiple body
types and gender Expressions Target also
says a collection of children's books
focused on lgbtq issues Target is evil
if a company targets kids that company
shouldn't exist Bud Light them to the
conservative media personality
personality Liz wheeler Matt Walsh of
course was saying this is worse than
anything Bud Light has done of course
and so the reporting apparently is that
we have this from the post-millennial
Target to move Pride merch to the back
of stores to avoid Bud Light situation
quote we were given 36 hours told to
take all of our pride stuff the entire
section and move it into a section
that's a third of the size
that's amazing
Bud Light is seeing another major drop
in sales they're nearly 30 percent down
year over year you'd love to see it it's
getting worse and worse for them
conservatives simply said we have no
brand loyalty to Bud Light this is the
scariest thing in the world for the
biggest brands there's no brand loyalty
to Target nobody's walking around
wearing Target charts being like yeah go
Target Bud Light at least had some brand
recognition with sports and that didn't
do anything for them so when it comes to
your choice between Target and Walmart
if people are going to be like Target's
bad we won't go there it's not a big
deal to shop somewhere else I really
hope that conservative stick to this
because a few years ago we saw a similar
attempt to boycott Target when they were
saying we're going to allow men to use
the women's room and abdicate our
responsibility to protect female patrons
in our stores and conservative said I'm
never shopping at Target again and then
many of them started shopping at Target
again so I hope that this is truly a
bridge too far in that people are going
to stick to it this time I would also
say that if this isn't stuck to it's
going to set a very bad precedent right
because people are seeing this as the
sort of sequel to the Bud Light boycott
and if it falls apart here that's going
to say a lot about the power of
conservatives as
protesters or as boycotters of products
honestly I don't think you really need
to identify as conservative to have
issues with child sex changes I'm not
that conservative really in life but
little kids that are getting their
parents are like cutting their body
parts off and stuff like that just as a
human I I kind of wonder what in the
hell is going on Tim's what was that Ian
I didn't I couldn't hear what you were
saying as I was pulling out this
wonderful stud light lager if anybody
would like it stop life stud light feel
free to grab a cannon this is uh no joke
I don't know if you can see it uh stud
light stud light and there's a there's a
cowboy on it for the horse uh and it's
from Harvest Gap Brewery in Hillsboro uh
Virginia that's hilarious so we just we
were just driving past this Brewery and
we walked in and I noticed they had
something called stud light
that's really good I'm uh I'm not a big
Beer Drinker but I had no choice but to
buy a beer called stud light with a
manly cowboy on it because I have to
wonder I'm not saying the brewery did
anything to uh what you want to just
grab one yeah here here you go yeah plus
we got a bunch down there surgery yeah
whatever you don't take it I'm not I'm
not saying that I don't know if this
Brewery made this intentionally because
of what was happening but to see that
they've got stud light and there's a
cowboy on it I was like I kind of feel
like you know they're they're having fun
super fun and it's a light lager and
it's pretty good yeah but anyway I just
I just thought it'd be funny if we just
cracked something if you look if you
look at Bud light's Market though I mean
you know you know what Ian was talking
about just to be offended by targeting
kids for this is a whole different
cross-section than just conservatives
but if you look at who shops at Target
it's not as much like who buys your
stuff at Target I mean a little bit of
everybody but who drinks Bud Light I
mean mean yeah the people that used to
drink Bud Light uh aren't going to go
along with this whole trans movement
kind of Dylan Mulvaney kind of thing and
they're also not going to buy it was an
April Fool's joke and so Bud Light made
a bad situation worse by not owning it
yeah and and now okay their ESG score
took a tally instead of owning that
they're still trying to to oh but see
but we can do everything and it's like
no man this is a tea intersection you're
gonna have to pick you can either keep
the people that used to drink Bud Light
or you can go woke
um
I think the thing with the Bud Light and
Target is that
target has it is smart of them to panic
in the way they're panicking yeah and
they should probably just remove these
products because the left will try and
lie but um look I don't care what an
adult wants to do you know uh you know
Sheamus and I love a disagreement on
this like I don't care about someone
who's lgbtq or whatever privacy of your
own home these are all the old
traditional arguments from liberals you
live your life you be happy you we mind
our own business keep the kids out of it
they're now trying to argue that the
lgbtq stuff is not inherently sexual yep
it's quite literally what it is
LGBT quite literally are references to
sexual identities and sexualities
there's no reason for you to bring that
to children
this is what Target is doing they should
not be doing that here's what I think
Bud Light loses about 25 of its its its
Market with this whole stunt and they're
not going to get it back they they may
still see growth because new people
under the market and population is well
if the population expands if it doesn't
then they're going to lose more more
drinkers
but I don't think it'll go to zero right
they've seen about a 30 drop off so far
it's like 28 or something like that
these are the people who pay attention
who don't want to drink Bud Light don't
want to be seen drinking Bud Light so a
lot of people don't care they don't
watch the news they don't they're not on
Twitter they're not on the internet they
just went to the they went to the liquor
store to get some beer and they said Bud
light's half off and they went wow me
and my buddies want to get drunk we'll
take it half off some people might even
know and just be like don't know don't
care cheap beer with Target I think
you'll see something similar a lot of
people who know will just say I will not
shop there anymore that's why Target is
freaking out not because they're gonna
go to business but because they could
lose 30 percent of their customers in a
month and that's bad news I I agree with
basically everything you're saying
there's just one thing I'd probably
phrase differently and I think you'd
actually agree with me on this when you
said there's no reason for them to be
introducing the sexual stuff to children
we know there's a reason we know what
the reason is it's because they want to
groom these kids
yeah Target I think the people at Target
who are trying to normalize this yeah
there's there's an entire effort within
our systems to push sexually perverse
behaviors onto children it's they're
owned by Vanguard BlackRock State Street
these companies keep popping up any uh
anything any of these publicly traded
things I mean those three corporations
BlackRock Vanguard and State Street own
like 24 of Target they are pushing an
agenda I completely agree with you
Sheamus and it is it is bad look um you
know my kids are at a point where I
never thought gee we need to cover boys
are different than girls and all that
stuff it's you know pretty pretty
intuitive but we're at an age where you
know they're very overtly introducing
this to kids and people say well you
know Ginger's a spectrum and it's
totally different than sex uh no you're
given cross-sex hormones you're using
cross-sex pronouns and the surgeries
that you want to do including to minors
are on the sexually distinctive physical
attributes of your Anatomy you cannot
change you're either an XY person male
or an XX person you can't change your
bone structure everything else you can't
change those attributes with rare
exception yeah like points it's out
there there are some uh there's some
there's some variants but that's not
what we're having this debate about
right you know those sections at Target
and you know the whole transgenderism
movement that's going on in the country
of spreading all over the place isn't
the traditional you know cross
uh you know issue with hormones that
come their DNA chromosome uh issues that
you're talking about so look at XY
people they're different than XX people
uh everyone has gotten that for all of
time until very recently
yeah no absolutely you mentioned this
point about us having to debate the
differences between boys and girls and
you not thinking you'd be at this point
I feel similarly I first became
interested in politics when I was about
eight years old because I I learned what
abortion was and it was so shocking to
me that anyone could consider that a
morally acceptable thing or that it
would be legal and so I've been
interested in these things from a very
early age and I had some hope as a kid
that by the time I was an adult if I
ever had any kind of political career or
a career in commentary we would have
moved on to other issues and Society
might have progressed of course my
optimism was misplaced here we are 20
years later and we're we're debating the
differences between boys and girls
literally well we've completely
regressed I don't think we're debating
them I think there is a cult that will
lie cheat and steal so they'll come to
you and pretend like there's a debate to
trick you into debating them because
they know that you'll operate in good
faith debate those ideas interesting
meanwhile I mean look I know I think
there's truth in that it's the video of
Jack besoba getting punched by the
leftist and then when the cops pull up
because the cops watch it happen the
leftists one of them goes I didn't see
anything happen they're just lying about
everything they know the difference
between boys and girls they're just
trying to destroy the system it seems
like yeah when you when you disrupt the
system it's the person that's the most
powerful that suffers the most so like
if you cut everybody's value by five
percent it's the rich it's the one with
the most value that's going to lose the
most because five percent of the most is
more than five percent of less than that
so like covid shut down the entire world
the United States probably suffered the
most because it was doing the best uh
and now we've got the disruption of the
Youth of the psychology of the youth the
United States has the most to lose
because it's the leader of the planet
and I don't think it's I don't think
it's an accident man it's a global
internet when you cut off the Tall Grass
the Short Grass stays where it is I I'm
gonna I'm gonna slightly push back
against both things I hear what you're
saying and I think I I agree overall but
when it comes to
who can suffer the most so for example
you're right that someone who's
extremely wealthy and loses five percent
of their wealth has lost more material
wealth technically speaking but if a
poor person is living paycheck to
paycheck and then they lose five percent
of their wealth maybe they can't afford
to pay rent anymore and similarly we saw
during covid the the UN increased the
number of people projected to be at risk
for starvation in the third world by
like 130 million so there are certain
things that Western countries can
tolerate that poorer countries can't and
that's actually part of why you see it
here right because we are so wealthy
that we've been able to insulate
ourselves from natural consequences for
decades if you had a poorer Society the
sexual Revolution would have fallen
apart almost immediately because what
happens when a man starts impregnating
women and then he doesn't care for those
children right I mean it's it's social
and economic pandemonium and very
wealthy Nations can insulate themselves
from that for a little while leftism
only exists in in wealthy Nations that's
right that's exactly it the woke mind
virus is Elon Musk kind of tagged it is
really only in affluent countries
there's no like big woke mind virus
spreading all over Africa they're not
transgender outbreaks all over the
global South it's in affluent countries
it's it's you know I talked about this
too a while ago when I said feminism can
only exist in in a in an Empire is
sphere the United States is so secure
that we no longer fear for our women
if you go back to to uh tribal era
medieval whatever when you're really
worried about wild animals and disease
you stub your toe you die the men are
very desperately like if the women die
we are wiped out as a civilization so
the women are protected keep them in
homes keep them in the camps around them
you get to the point where you have a
very strong military a very expansive
country crime gets goes way down and we
start exuding military force out of the
country and so we Face very little
threats from within then all of a sudden
there's nothing to worry about with
women reaching higher positions in
government I know this one probably
triggers the feminists but this is why
you don't see these things like you
mentioned in other parts of the world
where they are less affluent less safe
less secure very true if if we lived in
a violent Society where people got
attacked and and shot at and stabbed and
raped outside just walking down the
street it would be risky to send your
wife out to the grocery store it
wouldn't happen as much the guy would be
the one that did that it still is it
still is a Trope of don't walk down a
dark alley and the feminists have been
trying there's this weird inflection
point where crime was down enough to
where the left started saying stop
victim blaming but for the longest time
we would tell people don't go walk
through a dark alley at night and women
should be should be worried despite the
fact that men are more likely to be
victims of violent crime it's also true
that men are more likely to physic to be
able to physically defend themselves
from another man and but it's but it's
not just about men I'm talking about
wild animals and just general danger if
you go way back to humans and try in the
tribal in a tribal era if 90 if you have
a tribe if you have 100 men and 100
women and 99 women die that tribe ceases
to exist if 99 men die they'll struggle
but they'll probably be okay well it's
not even just a calculation right it's
men caring about the women in their
lives and recognizing because they're
not insulated from the consequences of
their actions by an unfathomable amount
of wealth that men and women do have to
be in different roles in order to be
maximally safe and so this is something
that you have to be unbelievably wealthy
to even start to consider as a society
the idea that you would start to swap
roles between men and women when you're
living in a state of nature right when
you're one bad Harvest away from your
entire family style starving you're not
like preoccupied with whether you were
called bossy when a man would have been
called assertive it's not even a
question and it's not to say that a
society where people are worried about
starving all the time is better however
I will say there's no argument to be
made that those people aren't stronger
and more virtuous than we are today and
I'll also add that we could have the
best of both worlds if people were
capable of living with wealth while
still having a spirit of poverty there's
no generational memory that's the
problem we we cannot we we don't know
what it's like to to you know be
preparing for Harvest some people do but
you know United States and to say we've
only three months of food prepared for
the winter yeah we're in trouble we're
going to have to eat less and Hunt more
if we're gonna make it through this one
yeah and I mean if you look on balance I
mean one of my favorite sites out there
is like human progress.org everyone's
like oh you know we got too many people
we're never going to make it you know
the malthusians were saying that forever
they were wrong on balance human
progress is great the innovation's given
us lots of flexibility but the question
is how do we keep the the ties that bind
us I mean you know part of our motto is
this idea of e pluribus unum and and
part of the way that you teach that is
values and cultures shared values and
you think about how easy it was you go
back to you know what you guys are
talking about the state of nature if
everyone could live by just a basic
truth of don't hurt people and don't
take their stuff uh we would really not
even need government right everything
would work just fine and because people
can't abide by that simple Maxim well
somebody's got to be the judge of well
who was wrong to hurt whoever here and
look at how much government we have now
versus how little we could have If
people could simply not hurt one another
or take their stuff we have a
constitution that's supposed to have a
limited form of government but now we
have far more government than will fit
within our Constitution and I think the
challenge today is how do we get a
government small enough to fit back in
the Constitution because we can afford a
government that small I think uh I think
just conflict will emerge conflict will
emerge I think that uh
we look at things that are um
we look at hard times as bad things but
I don't think they are I think there
needs to be a balance between the good
times and the bad times to create strong
well-balanced individuals who are
capable of surviving hard times and I
feel like you know there's a saying uh
Good Times make weak men week men you
know hard times Etc but I also feel like
it's kind of swinging back and forth
like a pendulum increasing the amount of
energy each time
you get a good time then you get weak
men which give you a hard time and then
it keeps swinging back and forth in
terms of the the
of how extreme it gets what I'm trying
to say is right now we are dealing with
a very serious crisis in the United
States and in other parts of the world
with actual War
we have many many weak men in fact I
think this country is the overwhelming
majority of men in this country are are
weak for example in New York Daniel
Penny defends people on a train
did anybody in New York come out with
signs to protest for Daniel Penny maybe
a couple here and there but was there
like a big March where the police were
yelling at them and they're blocking car
saying he's a hero no we don't see that
we do however see a lot of people
putting up a lot of money which for a
lot of people can be even more
courageous if you're seriously if you're
saying like I'm going to take a portion
of my resources and allocated defending
defending this man so my point is not
that there are no strong men or strong
people but then in places like New York
and these big cities you are more likely
to see people say
I better keep my head down and not
engage and I was saying this to Glenn
Beck earlier
I don't think the problem is that evil
exists I think the problem is that good
men do nothing yeah it's a great quote
for a reason and you go back to the
Declaration of Independence you know
they pledged their lives their Fortunes
in their sacred honor because that's
what it takes to defend a country and
that's look we're only the the land of
the free if we are in fact the home of
the brave and it does take courage
whether it's to cut a check to show up
to an event to participate you got to
make the current system work or it is
going to fail strength also is kind of
uh like Darwin would say it's not the
strongest of the species that survives
but the most adaptable to change it's
the most adaptable humans that get by
which I think is why people aren't
stepping up sometimes is because they
want to just get by they want to fit in
to survive but you know sometimes you
need people to break the mold I wanna I
wanna jump down yeah I want to piggyback
on that because I think that's a very
very good point were you finished though
I'm not sure okay so I think that's a
very good point and one thing I would
argue is that
virtue is what makes you adaptable right
a person who's living a life of Vice is
taking the path of least resistance and
what they're doing is engaging in
behaviors that feel good for them in the
moment rather than behaving rationally
making a long-term plan and behaving
based on what's going to be good for
them down the line when you're able to
do that when you're able to use your
rational faculties to like subordinate
your passions to what's going to be good
for you in the long run you can adapt to
many different kinds of situations but
if you've made yourself accustomed
simply to or accustomed simply to doing
whatever feels good for you well once
the dynamic changes you're gonna have
absolutely no idea how to interact with
the world I want to jump to this story
from timcast.com Montana Governor signs
Bill defining male and female governor
Greg gianforte was lobbied by his adult
son to oppose Senate Bill 458 and other
bills regulating gender issues
they say he signed Senate Bill 458 in
the law May 19th the bill States the
term female refers to a member of the
human species who under normal
development has access Chrome XX
chromosomes and produces or would
produce relatively large relatively
immobile gametes or eggs during her life
cycle and as a reproductive and
endocrine system oriented around the
production of those gametes including an
individual who would otherwise fall
within this definition but for a
biological or genetic condition
Additionally the state will not
recognize mail to meet a member of the
human species who under normal
development has X Y chromosomes and
produces or would produce small mobile
gametes or sperm during his life cycle
and has a reproductive and endocrine
system oriented around the production of
those gametes including an individual
who would otherwise fall within this
definition but for biological or genetic
condition
so I'm curious if they included this and
anything pertaining to intersex because
there there are several different
um genetic uh
circumstances where a person may have X
Y chromosomes we totally appear totally
female and that's like Androgen
insensitivity disorder or syndrome or
something like that so someone's
biologically male but their body does
not in any way react to testosterone so
when they're born they look like girls
and they grow up they look like girls
and it's like hey wait a minute that's
actually a guy whose testosterone never
worked and then there's also people
um there's a variety of uh syndromes
where people could be x y y or xxy I'm
wondering how it defines them yeah I
will say however
this is a particularly interesting
considering the transgender rep you know
in in Montana we mentioned mentioned in
the article the bill was one of several
gender related policies passed during a
contentious legislative session
prompting a vitriolic protest from
transgender identifying representative
Zoe Zephyr that led to an official
censure the fact that we've come to the
point where we have to Define male and
female is is fascinating to me and there
was a there's an article I was reading
recently I think it was the daily mail
that referred to a transgender male that
is somebody who is male but wants to be
a woman as a female
and the media does this thing which is
very strange where they will call males
females and females male I think that's
why they have to do this so what happens
is first we say we hear man is a social
construct women is a social construct
you can be a biological male but be a
woman if you're trans that's what the
left argues then they started just once
again changing the words and saying
trans female
now if you're born male but want to be
female they call you transgender female
which is not and never was the actual
description of of what the person was
yeah exactly and so this is something
I've noticed where conservatives are now
shocked that the left has redefined male
and female which is perplexing to me
because why would that be shocking when
they redefine man and woman why would
you think they redefine those words but
they're not going to redefine male and
female and strip them all meaning well
of course they were going to you can't
like retreat into that linguistic
territory we and expect them not to
muddle that up either and we had uh
Lance from the serfs the leftist
I said someone asked what is a woman and
he says easy an adult human female and I
said oh okay so trans women are not
women he goes no they are trans women
are female he said yeah I'm just
thinking about Lance that makes no sense
I explained to him that men that
transitioned to be trans women are trans
women and men at the same time they
don't stop being one to become the other
they become both and he was like no
that's not what they think but but he
was telling me like what the current
brainwashing is is that they don't but
the reality is you never stop being
human when you become a trans man or a
trans woman you're still a human you're
still a man and now you're a trans woman
and a man and a human but uh Ian's
completely right he's touching us if
you're an adult human male you're a man
and then if you are transgender you are
a trans woman but you are still an adult
human male well oh sorry I just think
that the definition is pretty good and
it does get after what you say but for a
biological or genetic condition yeah
yeah that would be the things that you
were alluding to uh so you know but
there's the interesting thing there then
is there may be someone who presents
completely as female because of like
Androgen and sensitivity and has spent
their whole life believing they were a
woman only to find out when they're in
their you know late 20s so what does
that mean do they lose protections or
are people going to see I mean I think I
I look forward to the day that we're
back focused on that like
.01.005 of the population I hope that's
where we get back to because right now
we're talking about it to the point
where oh you have to introduce your
five-year-old to this and buy them gear
at Target I mean this is just a crazy
place and it's on on purpose frankly not
for a lot of people that are struggling
with it I think the real question is you
know why are so many people struggling
with it you know so uh you went from in
in 2013 in the United States I think
there were two gender clinics and now
you have hundreds if not thousand plus
of them all over the country like what
happened all of human history you don't
have this now suddenly it's everywhere I
think the real question is why well
there were also just two genders back
then and now there's hundreds across the
country social media is a big factor and
I think endocrine disruptors are big are
a big factor so I think I I I was
wondering this you know I was listening
to some old old rock
and didn't it am I just wrong about this
that rock stars used to be a little bit
older and gruffer and thicker like I
don't know men just seemed manlier back
in the day dirty dirtier definitely
dirtier yeah but maybe that's just how
media you know portrayed people and now
they're trying to change it or something
but there there is a Trope among
Millennials where they're like you watch
these old movies and you're like wait a
minute that dude was 30. they look like
they're 50. why is it that everybody
looks so much younger today yeah I'm
wondering if endocrine disruptors have
been screwing with us for the past
couple of decades the past few
Generations because Plastics are a new
thing for human civilization Plastics
and vaccines I mean if you look at RFK
RFK for you know uh the Democratic
presidential candidate uh he's talked
about vaccines for a long time you know
uh look I got vaccinated against I was
in the Army I mean I I didn't know that
you could function as an adult without
getting shots until I got out of the
army and my doctor said oh yeah you
don't actually need shots but like every
time I went to see a doctor I was
getting vaccinated against something but
if you look at kids that came up in this
era over the past you know few decades
they've never gone up in an era where
they didn't have lots of vaccines some
people say it's that I just think we
should have an honest uh investigation
as to you know what did change I think I
don't I wouldn't want to isolate just
vaccines I think big Pharma in general
the amount of pills medications whatever
you want to call it we're giving kids
more shots than ever we're giving them
more pills than ever we are we've got
chemicals loaded up on our food
something's happening yeah it's
fantastic it's birth control too yeah
don't acknowledge that there's a lot of
excess estrogen that just gets peed back
out into the water supply I I was
thinking like I learned about
amphetamines and like dare and like
third grade and I was like oh
amphetamines are like they get you going
there they get you speed they're they're
nasty drugs like the Gateway leads you
to amphetamines amphetamines of the dark
and then all of a sudden Adderall it's
an amphetamine and it's I think it's I
think it's like four different
amphetamines or something like that like
it's a combination and you're actually
considering giving most of the children
like you're not but considering they do
yeah so so it my point is when we're
talking about first you know because the
original subject was male and female and
trans stuff I would not be surprised if
well I I will first say it is a fact
look this up there was a birth control
that masculine or not masculinized uh
young girls
uh it because of the exposure to this
birth control in women resulted in the
female fetus becoming masculinized and
that we read about it on the show
so birth control is doing this
then we also know that Plastics are
endocrine disruptors that's why use we
use the the glass bottles
and uh liquid death had a funny
commercial recently about people getting
plastic shoved in their bodies to make
their like butts bigger and they're like
plastic surgery or whatever it was funny
because they're they're all about using
aluminum cans out of plastics because
Plastics are bad but I do think a large
component is social pressures which is
why we see typically it's like the
overwhelming majority of trans kids are
female because they're being pressured
by social media but then I do think one
of the reasons we're seeing
some of this may just be people are
suffering from endocrine disruption
their bodies aren't producing the right
hormones and the bright right levels and
this is not some right-wing conspiracy
theory right the data has shown that
testosterone has been decreasing for the
past few decades now this is a real oh
yeah I was just learning about
apparently when a man sees a woman comes
into contact with a woman his
testosterone spikes by 20 roughly this
is some some things I just learned I
don't know if it's real or not but it
sounds cool and so I'm wondering if all
this interaction with women digitally
like watching movies with women in it
and watching porn for instance is
getting this like the body stops
producing the testosterone Spike because
it's not getting the reciprocity from
the woman so it realizes like okay she's
not really there she's not really there
and then when you see a woman in real
life she's not really there like we're
becoming adapted that's not had this
testosterone Spike I hear what you're
saying but I feel like that's way too uh
there's too many leaps happening it's a
long shot if anything
looking at all these women would
increase men's testing you would think
so but then if it happens over and over
and over and over and you're not getting
the the value of the testosterone the
body might just stop doing it because
it's like well there's at least a
correlation between wealth and uh
poverty right so if you look what's
going what's different in wealthy
countries than in poor countries and
there are so many different things but I
do think that that it'd be worthwhile
subject but today I mean look this uh
this uh professor at Brown she she got
canceled she was one of the first cancel
culture people in it I mean she's an
atheist professor at Brown and she
started going well what happens with
like okay there's someone who's
transgender and then in their peer group
once one person identifies as
transgender lots of other people in that
school or in that peer group start to
identify as transgender too and she
coined it sudden onset gender dysphoria
because she wanted to investigate it and
gave it a label but the whole APA uh you
know Psychological Association went
after her canceled her got her
unpublished and everything she'd written
scholarly journals and she was going at
it from an academic perspective they've
literally worked to kill any serious
academic study into yeah what does
explain this and it was just an
intellectual curiosity like well why is
it all of a sudden spreading to other
people versus you know the biological or
genetical issues that were referenced in
the Montana law yeah well this is also
interesting too right because they'll
argue that this idea of social contagion
is also a far-right conspiracy theory
but the president of wpath which is like
the leading transgender activism
organization on the planet has
acknowledged that social contagion is
driving in some part the massive surge
of kids who are now identifying as trans
yeah you also call it peer pressure
that's what used to call in the 80s well
isn't it so crazy that they would even
try to get away with saying teens aren't
doing things because of peer pressure of
course they are dude how could you say
there's this one category of behavior
that's immune to peer pressure
of their parents and their their the law
basically control from their parents
yeah if a 14 year old can be like now
because I say this you all have to bow
to me and I'm 13 but like what a power
surge for a young human to be able to be
like all I got to do is say I'm trans
and then I can depending on the state
the doctors will be alike come right in
and we'll have those old boys removed
you can get like teachers fired if they
don't don't agree with you you can get
politicians like it's crazy but
psychotic power is involved yes no it's
true why is jump in social standing
massively which is what young people
want there's more social status it's not
so much about social status and Ian's
point is talking about Authority and
control but they're the system they're
the same right the more social status
you have the more control you have over
the system no I just like the most
social status you could possibly have is
to be in full control socially and
legally I disagree
um people want to just give you things
be around you and you know in terms of
authority you could be the most hated
person in the world but everyone gives
you stuff but I would say I would say
that somebody who is in a position of
legal Authority but is hated has a lower
social status than someone who's in a
position of legal Authority and who
everybody lies I'm saying that they both
play a role in Social Status like if our
law is privileged for sure women they
have a higher Social Status now like to
a certain degree you can argue that
people are attracted to someone of great
governmental wealth but there's a
balance yeah if you are the
ugliest most out of shape smelliest you
know dude living in a basement all right
I get it you can you can Ian you can go
out well in New York and you can dress
up in in historical con period according
to New York law
and they are forced to give you what you
want you can force a massive
multi-billion dollar Corporation to do
whatever you want that doesn't mean you
have any good social status yeah so and
that's kids in general have no social
issue actually that people have no
social status are going and exploiting
the system well but I would say that if
there are laws that are written that
tell people they're not allowed to
disagree with you their social status in
that right legal system privileges
groups of people everybody's privileged
to know what a status yeah 100 so if the
law says anyone can do whatever they
want there's no social status yeah but
my argument is not that social stuff I
understand that there has to be a
differential like some people have to be
lower in Social Status than other for
others for like the legal question to
apply my point is simply that when one
group of people are set aside by the law
and said they have special privileges
that increases social status but I'm
talking about how the law does not
protect a group of people it's random
the New York City law says anything you
do is protected it's literally anything
so the the a homeless person of no
social status has control in a system if
they choose to that's not social status
that's just a broken system I'm not so
my initial response to what Ian was
saying is that creating these quote
unquote transgender protections boosts
the social status of people who have
that identity like that identified label
what I'm trying to clarify is that's not
the case you don't think so you don't
think that that boosts their social
status the fact that they go around
telling people they have to use their
pronouns or that employers
do it for anything right so the law
doesn't say you have to use someone's
she her he and pronouns it says anyone
who says anything has to be respected
I'm just going to say in New York if
you're if you're a black man and defend
uh anything Conservative then you must
be a white supremacist right so I mean
well I do think there's something I
don't know whether it's called social
status or whatever but you have all
these people that it's like if you step
out of what they're you know one of my
colleagues referred to somebody we don't
need any more Brown faces that aren't
Brown voices or black faces that aren't
black voices or things like that and
it's like well you know Tim Scott's like
I'm not supposed to talk uh you know and
and so there is this kind of
I don't know heresy code I don't know
whether it's status or whatever but kind
of this whole kind of woke culture has
got its own heresy code there is no
doctrine of grace over there you cross
the line you're canceled and so I think
to your point yeah there's a but that's
highly selective in terms of where you
would even have status I mean yeah some
Perry some areas not gonna your status
goes even worse and maybe even in Peril
when they say that anyone can dress in a
historical period costume they're not
privileging transgender people they are
basically saying anyone can wear and
dress and be called whatever they demand
and you must adhere to it
if they said if someone who is
traditionally male appears in
non-traditional you know or appears as
female presents in female stereotypical
clothing using female names you cannot
just go down this basis that would be
outlining just trans people but New
York's law it's the weirdest thing I've
ever seen it says you can dress in
historical period like those words
actually appear in the law which means
you could dress up like a pirate in New
York City and say I'm pirate gender and
it's protected not even asking and your
Pirates could be R and matey and it's
that's not a group of pirates are not
protected but they are now that's my
point yeah Pirates are not protected
gender in New York City you are a
privileged class this is something that
Jordan Peterson said in response to bill
c-16 which I thought was a great
observation which is that what a lot of
these protection laws do is they
enshrine
um a person's fashion Choice as like a
legally protected identity so I'm
wondering could I go in and chain mail
or or like plate yes yes I identify as a
knight from the Middle Ages so so look
I've brought this up time and time again
where the lawyers told me and I will get
laughed out of the courtroom but the New
York civil rights law Set uh Human
Rights Commission says historical period
I have no idea why that's that's kind of
insane it's not gender identified but it
literally says it meaning you can put on
a full plate armor and be like these are
my clothes we talked about this a while
ago right yeah and that's right we
actually have a lawyer on the show and
they were basically saying that I think
we were joking about wearing a fursuit
or something and saying like that and he
said I mean legally yeah but you'd
probably get laughed out of the
courtroom well no I talked to I talked
to several human rights lawyers who told
me that I so this is 2019 or whatever I
call a bunch of lawyers and I said what
would happen if someone did this and
they said everyone knows the point of
the law you'd get left out of the
courtroom
the problem is now is they've expanded
it there's there's there's there's no
way this makes sense when they added the
words historical period because now it's
you can dress up like like I mentioned
you know put on a safari costume and a
big white fake beard and call yourself
the colonel and they can't they that's
protected the historical period is
protected yeah I think at some point you
know a lot of the country's just like
yeah we're gonna move on you guys go
ahead and do that
um and we're not going to go along with
it and that's kind of where this whole
effort to counter that it goes with Bud
Light like man we're just you do it go
do your thing as an adult whatever you
are but I'm not drinking Bud Light
anymore we talked about that last night
how do you see like the value and
differential between political power and
I guess private sector power like well
there's obviously some sort of
correlation between power and money
right so uh I don't think that's new to
our culture or any other place around
the world but you know if you look at if
you look at um you know influence uh you
know at some point cultural influence
really drives the politics I mean a lot
of times people say in a fun functioning
democracy you get the government you
deserve you get what you voted for and
people will get frustrated by what we
get and it's it's hard to believe that
you know you could have you know
Marjorie Taylor green uh when 80 of the
vote in her district and you know
um
you know AOC when 80 of the vote in her
district and people love them both but
they're so very different and I think
that's gets to like our constitution
actually is designed to have that kind
of flexibility but somehow in the era
that we're in there's this idea that
everything has to be federalized and I
think that's the problem it's like yeah
you can actually do your thing in New
York and do it your way Ohio we're not
going to do that probably uh and you
know if you really want to you could
maybe do it in a certain area but we're
not going to change our laws like New
York did and Texas may do it totally
different but if you want to make it all
one big federal policy and just cram it
down your throat that's the tension
people are trying to seize power in
Washington and impose their will on
everyone else yeah I think one massive
problem with the direction the United
States has gone and really over the past
hundred years is to create an analogy
we've gone from a neighborhood to an
apartment building so when you're in a
neighborhood everyone has their own
house they have their own lawn they can
make decisions about their house they
can add something on to it subtract
something from it have a guard did not
have a garden on chickens whatever it is
right in your all houses you're all in
the neighborhood you all have the same
zip code but you're able to make
decisions about your own property
there's some sovereignty there might be
an HOA that puts some limitations on it
but overall you can make your own choice
for your own property now it's like the
United States has become a condominium
and each state is its own little condo
and you're able to make decisions and
it's technically your own property as a
state or as the governor of a state or
as the people of a state but you're not
fully Sovereign because
there's a certain pattern you have to
follow so that you don't move outside of
the status quo of what is like
architecturally sound for that building
but Ronda Santos was able to tell him to
shove it during the covid attempted
shutdowns so you would still consider
him in the apartment complex but just
like I would say he's trying to make
moves out yeah I would say I would say
that like he's sort of starting to shift
the Paradigm because what happens is
when you have an incredibly strong
federal government
each state becomes more affected by
decisions made in other states in a way
where they historically were not when
the government didn't have as much
oversight or when the federal government
didn't have as much oversight and so
what I think DeSantis is doing and again
analogies limp and where this one falls
apart is that we can actually you know
disassemble the condominium and put
people back onto their own property and
I think Governors like DeSantis move us
in that direction by pulling away from
federal oversight I want to jump to
another crazy story
hard to say wait we got this in the
Daily Mail second Hunter Biden IRS
whistleblower comes forward agent
claimed he was passed over for promotion
and removed from tax investigation team
for claiming the president's son was
getting preferential treatment they say
a new case agent who has not been
identified says he was fired last last
week without any explanation after
working on the hunter Biden
investigation since 2018 his complaint
comes days after it was revealed the doj
removed his entire team according to his
supervisor IRS commissioner Daniel
warfel had told Congress the agency
wouldn't retaliate against
whistleblowers in April
so if you are the son of uh the
president
you get away with committing crimes if
you're the son of this President
right because because Don Jr couldn't
get away with not committing crimes
right like they were threatening him
you're trying to lock him up for
literally nothing they put his face on
Time Magazine wrote red to hand it and
he didn't do anything
you can't catch someone right-handed
when they actually didn't do anything
it's wild but this is how they lie right
it has to be as far as possible from the
truth it's not a small little light it's
not a white lights we caught this guy
doing something red-handed when they
didn't even have evidence because
nothing happened
yeah nothing happened you know who has
been caught red-handed all right the guy
who has pictures smoking a crack pipe in
them that's who's been caught red-handed
look in the look not only did he get
caught handed red-handed the the whole
uh Coalition of intelligence experts got
caught red-handed concocting the story
to cover for Hunter Biden's laptop and
look kudos to Tucker Carlson for
highlighting this in the 2020 election
cycle but frankly it got dropped right
away one of the guys in the middle of
that Tony bobolenski uh came forward did
the interview with Tucker Carlson and
said look if it's Russian disinformation
how am I carbon copied on the same email
uh I got an email we were part of the
same deal flow like how did I wind up
this is true I know this is true and I
told you know everyone at the time look
I know Tony I will vouch for this guy
he's telling you the truth uh and the
story was dead everyone killed it and
you know this is why what happened what
Matt taibi is working on it at Twitter
and the Twitter files is so important
because you see they weren't just doing
this at Twitter they were doing this all
over uh and it might not be the exact
same cast of characters that wrote the
cover story for Hunter Biden's laptop
but it is the same Coalition of three
letter agencies that are using the power
of the government to cancel speech in
America and whether it was political
speech or coveted speech you still think
back to like I mean for me I always like
like uh you know Dwight Eisenhower big
deal at West Point big deal for the
country very successful General uh I
think very successful president and
underappreciated but his Farewell
Address he said you know cautioned
against the military industrial complex
we saw that play out for a long time
used to be the left was anti-military
industrial complex they can't get enough
of it lately but the other thing he
cautioned against was the scientific
technical Elite and if Saint fauci
doesn't epitopize the uh scientific
technical Elite look what was going on
in the midst of all this stuff and at
the center of dominating both of those
are these three little agents disease
canceling and covering and all for
political influence operations
for the left they accused a sitting
president of treason and they targeted
his family and now we have questions
about what Joe Biden's doing and I tell
you the way it feels to me what what it
feels like to me is
this the nation is captured by corrupt
Elites The Establishment that's what we
refer to it as maybe it needs a
different name and we call it the Deep
state but these people don't care about
this country and there's something else
we were talking about this last night
when we we discussed the fall of Empire
the idea was that every 250 years the uh
they say you know Empire's collapse Phil
was talking about this he's like well
the U.S hasn't been an empire for 250
years it's only really since the end of
World War II
I think the fall of the American Empire
would be the greatest thing for the
United States
because the American Empires people
refer to it is this it's it's this uh
expeditionary force that we've sent all
over the world of military bases insane
foreign policy World policing and what
we need to get back to is our own
borders our own people our own jobs our
own economy and that's what Trump was
doing the people who oppose him are
those who want the American Empire they
want war in Syria they want pipelines in
Europe they want to control various
parts of the Middle East and we as
Americans don't care about any of that
but we're so long for the ride because
they're taking us there yeah no it's
very real and one thing you mentioned
about the left loving the
military-industrial complex I mean this
is one of Trump's greatest
accomplishments to be honest that he
pushed the war mongers and the warhawks
out of the Republican part you turn them
into Democrats
yeah look look and this is something
I've said repeatedly about Trump does
not surround himself with the best
people I mean he has really made some
some bad picks uh
as well exactly not sending his best not
all of us picked for bad that's for
certain but it definitely made some
mistakes there however my greater point
is
so many people so many hawks uh were
able to find refuge in the Democratic
party because they said initially or at
least they claim to say we don't like
war and they said you know what
we don't like War but we don't dislike
it as much as we dislike mean tweets I
have a mixed means military industrial
complex because I hated it from 2006
when I found out it existed I've never
known now you love it yeah and now I'm
like well like you know I'm kind of
pro-industrial member if we didn't have
American military bases all over Earth
then what would be the what would be the
other like I had never thought about
like what would be the the other option
if we got rid of the American military
industrial complex well there would
probably be a Chinese military
industrial complex they're probably like
Russian invasions all across and then
that would take so like
I don't like I'm not like just hey
America die I'm not trying to like stop
it out because like what it's so bad get
rid of it like what are your thoughts
yeah look I enlisted in the Army the
Cold War was going on right and you know
people think about the Soviet Empire was
there uh they were the Communists we
were the good guys uh and you know I
wanted to be part of defendant America
and so I look at the time Hunt for Red
October was a big deal the submarines
and the tanks and everything and I was
like I don't want to be in any of those
but I'll jump into airplanes that'll be
great so I wanted to be an Airborne
Ranger I got the chance to go do that I
get over to Germany the wall was still
up I mean we had live ammo on our
vehicles we were prepared for the
Soviets to come rolling over and the
wall goes down I was in um bad tolls
Germany the German Alps in the South uh
training with 10 special forces groups
and this guy stands on the podium and he
goes write this day down this is going
to be one of the most famous days in
history 9 November 1989 and I mean I was
a private so I didn't say this out loud
but I was like oh yeah pretty bold intro
to your talk you know but he goes the
wall just came down and we didn't know
whether he was real or not so like that
Thanksgiving go into Berlin and see
people for the first time I could speak
a little bit of German at the time this
guy could speak pretty good English and
he's like this is it like this
everywhere and we were in the kudon
district which is kind of like Times
Square you know Berlin's version of New
York's Times Square and I was like no
you know we have small towns and
everything he goes no the stores are
open at night and there's fresh milk and
I was like yeah you know I'm trying to
explain like a 7-Eleven or something to
him he goes no and there's like always
food on the shelves and like everyone
can go in because mine was blown I was
like yeah you want everyone to go in
because you saw more stuff but he was
told like we were even more poor than
they were we had two blocks for show uh
and you know the the elites could go in
and get things but you know the regular
people went somewhere else so the flow
at the end of the Cold War was not into
there other than a little bit of sense
of curiosity the flow was how do we be
more like the West you know when I was
in high school Ronald Reagan rode
through my town on a train and I got to
see him speak in Sydney Ohio and he said
said you know a lot of things at that
time one of his famous quotes is
Freedom's never more than one generation
away from Extinction but we're in an era
right now where people say they want
what was on the other side of the wall
they want they come in in Congress and
say they're they want socialism they
want Democratic socialism and I'll just
tell you the place where America is a
Force for good so to your point Ian
um the Korean Peninsula you look South
Korea south of the 38th parallel first
world economy First World Health Care
Mission sending country uh all kinds of
things they're a global donor to help
others around the world north of the
38th parallel they had the other
ideology Paradise yeah absolutely
Paradise up in North Korea that's right
yeah right and there's nothing going
wrong there but for America intervening
the whole Korean Peninsula would be like
North Korea yep and but for China I mean
look what China did we could have made
the whole Peninsula like South Korea but
China stopped it so look we do need a
strong military but we don't need an
Empire I mean I think look one of the
best uh book titles I don't know a
republic not an Empire we what did you
you know the question to Ben Franklin
what have you wrought sir a republic if
you can keep it and the real thing is we
lost our way how do we get back to a
constitution a government small enough
to fit inside that Constitution I'm
sorry or what concerns me is like the
Spanish-American War at the end of the
1800s uh Cuba was controlled by the
Spanish Empire so the United States
decided we're going to liberate Cuba
they did they attacked they they
dispelled the Spanish Fleet they
liberated Cuba they didn't take it we
could have made Cuba American territory
but instead because of the righteous
that we were we we let them become
independent and then they became a
communist threat so like at some point
where the value you of con of being the
one in control of the strength and
conquering and governing the world like
there is value to that yeah I'm just
terrified I don't know no I think that's
that's actually a really good point my
my eyes have been opened we we should
just go in and start taking over other
countries right now because we're better
than they are name a country their
economies are usually bad right there's
a lot of crime and Corruption Mexico
boom you know we already fought a
Mexican-American war and we couldn't
tape it we could have we could have but
the president who was it at the time was
it Polk I can't remember hippie he was
like nah we're not going to keep Mexico
we're gonna give Mexico back and people
in America were actually very much in
favor of keeping it after we won that
war and if we did would there be a big
problem with cartels now I'm not
seriously suggesting that we invade
other countries but fair question if the
United States did keep Mexico after that
war yeah would there be a problem with
cartels and crime and all that stuff I
don't think so I think there'd still be
massive demand for drugs I mean that's a
big problem I mean as long as there's
demand there's going to be Supply that's
the problem but right now the challenge
we're dealing with is look drugs have
been bad they've always been bad it's a
bad idea to take them in my opinion uh
but now they're being poisoned with
fentanyl right and so what where's the
fentanyl coming from it's coming from
China and you look I just got to think
we got to stop that we're voting on
bills today and look thankfully this is
now bipartisan stopping the fentanyl
because you know there's a girl in my
district Lizzie Murphy 21 years old took
a Xanax at a party bad idea but it was
laced with fentanyl one pill one party
killed her right and so that's happened
in tens of thousands of times like 70
000 Americans dead with fentanyl and to
your point if we had control of Mexico
look there might still be cartels
supplying something but we would not
have this kind of crisis on our hands
today and that's part of the challenge
today since uh you know the question is
can we unite to deal with this problem
and so many others
without conquering
oh hopefully without conquering you
think we can
uh I I think they're I think we can I'm
certainly not calling for an invasion of
Mexico
probably not lose what about but I don't
know I don't know tomorrow in Iraq if
this was all business I mean Canada we
would have already acquired them right I
mean but you know they have like 40 50
million people I mean it would be a
pretty easy acquisition uh they would
have better government than they have
today on the other hand look they've got
Trudeau and all this socialism cancel
culture Galore all kinds of the you know
Utopia that the far left in America
wants I would trade one far left uh
person who wants to fundamentally remake
America with critical theory Marxism for
one you know Freedom loving Canadian I
mean I might I might give you a 10 for
one deal you can have 10 of these far
left crazy people uh for one like
Freedom loving Canadian Canada
or Venezuelan or trying to escape people
who are like hey communism is bad
America is the dream and they want to be
here we're better off with just travel
just travel I feel like we are on the
cusp of of of the end of the American
military-industrial complex or at least
that's one option and I'm I'm really
like considering like if that does
happen and we become just the United
States of isolationism what's what are
we going to do like when another country
starts taking over its neighbors well so
this is an interesting question
so I want to mention something there's
this phrase like isolationism and I
understand like this is just sort of the
term people use politically but I don't
think not getting involved in Wars is
accurately described it as isolationism
right like you're not I mean if you're
still trading with other countries if
you have pro-social interactions with
other countries you're not isolated
you're just not fighting them I think
with the question of other countries
being invaded there's a real question
there there's a real concern because
there are human rights violations all
over the world but then also there are
human rights violations all over the
world I mean how do we decide which ones
we get involved who has the most
resources we can acquire that's why I'm
like it's just it's just all Bs we're
not invading China over there of their
concentration camps we're not look at
Eisenhower though go back to Eisenhower
look at he he didn't get called an
isolationist he ended the you know
pushed for the end of the uh Korean War
you know it ended you know as he was
campaigning to be president but you know
you look you look at you look at uh
winding that war down he could have
continued it and waged it uh at the end
of World War II is the last time we had
as much debt as we have today right and
and we knew like you can't you can't
have that much debt relative to the size
of your economy so the entire Global
monetary system was reset and everyone
knew you have to pay down the debt so
Eisenhower said we can't get involved
everywhere you have to be focused and I
think that's the time we're in today uh
we have to convince people look you
can't live with this much debt and even
if you say oh we can print more money
well haven't we just tested this that no
well you can print some money but you're
not going to be able to buy the same
amount of stuff inflation is real right
and so you can't just print your way out
of this you actually have to get back to
the discipline and focus that scarcity
produces and you know uh frankly
Republic uh keeps you that way but if
you want to try to build an Empire
that's why Empires fail is because they
over consume the resources that they've
got and that's really what's happening
and the neocons have done as much damage
in terms of debt and destruction of
Freedom as the far left is in our
country and that's why Trump's
presidency was so important we haven't
fully purged the party of these folks
but we need to finish the job and
frankly make sure the the neocons are
homeless well it's it's a complicated
question I would say the the left has
still done more damage just because of
the denigration to the family which is
the fundamental social building block
but fundamentally I agree with you that
neoconservatives have done a massive
amount of damage and frankly I wouldn't
really draw a distinction between the
neoconservatives and the left all of the
ideological founders of the
neoconservative movement were either
Marxist or former marxists right Irving
crystal said a neoconservative is uh a
leftist who's been mugged by reality
well I'm sorry reality doesn't mug you
the truth sets you free but whoever sold
you that Marxist ideology did mug you
and it's not true but what the
neoconservatives couldn't see was that
it wasn't reality that was corrupt it
was their insane ideology that was but
they still stuck to it and they believed
firmly and you can tell based on their
foreign policy that they believed this
that social order could be fundamentally
restructured in ways foreign to the
nature of man or a culture that's being
governed through the barrel of a gun and
with the threat of force of course we
can go to Iraq or Afghanistan and turn
these countries into modern democracies
because government can do anything you
threaten Force strategically in the
right areas you can completely reshape a
culture an entire culture I mean these
are fundamentally Marxist ideas I don't
think they work they don't it works
every time over the course of 80 years
and just genocide and the eradication of
living memory so we don't know like the
Romans just transformed Rome it used to
be you know a lot of different countries
before it was the Roman Empire but now
with modern media there's no way to do
that without everyone watching the the
torture and the annihilation of humanity
so we we kind of reject the idea of like
going into Iraq and just killing
everyone and planting the seed of
americanism that didn't wasn't going to
happen no one would have tolerated that
never so I think this top-down
transformation doesn't work anymore it's
not even happened in the United States
in Afghanistan
in a hundred years if we created the
culture there then I think it would be
like South Korea yeah but it would be so
brutal it would have to be sober like
killing people for speaking out against
the new regime kind of brutal it
wouldn't it wouldn't track with our
modern culture
yeah and it didn't and that's why we
just said we shouldn't be in there and
we should leave it's insane social
engineering right it's completely insane
social engineering similar vein but what
are your thoughts on this Ukrainian War
like what's your foreseal for like the
future of the end of this conflict and
one of a small group of people that's
never voted for anything for Ukraine and
it's not because I'm sympathetic to
Putin or anything it was an unjust
invasion of Ukraine
um and you know clearly the Russians
have I think there's enough evidence to
say they've they've they've violated
Norms to the point where they're they're
war crimes these things aren't
acceptable uh but there was a there was
a reason that there was a war there and
it was preventable I think um look you
can never say it wouldn't have happened
if Donald Trump was president but we
know that it didn't happen when he was
president uh and look weakness invites
aggression you know Joe Biden just oozes
weakness everywhere and when you look at
how this war is being waged it is a
proxy war it's Undeclared it it's
undefined you know there's no Mission
it's like well help Ukraine help them do
what
um you know and and oh we'll stop the
Russians okay look I mean there is no
military school anywhere where that's
going to get you a passing grade on a
mission statement is is the mission to
make sure that swore doesn't spread to
Nato is the mission to make sure there
are no Russians in Ukraine does that
include Crimea those are all different
missions that need different resources
is the mission regime change in Russia
because you're going to have war crimes
tribunals because you're not having war
crimes tribunals unless there's regime
change in Russia so there are people in
the state department that want that
Victoria Newland who spent you know the
better card of a decade working to
engineer this War uh and it frankly is
like rooting for it to be bigger
um yeah regime change in Russia and you
know look the basic uh phrase you know
Ready Aim Fire where's the aim part we
haven't even defined the mission I just
sent a letter last week to secretary
blinken like what do you you say the
mission is Mr secretary because you're
coming asking for more resources to do
what let's define the mission and I
think at some level any of those could
be just I mean it looks unjust what
Putin did so you could all go all the
way to regime change you could say look
Ukraine's not part of NATO it's just
that we defend NATO we're stopping right
here rooting for you but our focus is
here but you should Define it and if you
just have an open checkbook frankly it's
the worst of all outcomes because the
the ukrainians want their country they
will do anything to get it you give them
a lifeline and hope but it's on purpose
being turning these people into a meat
grinder so if you look at uh you know
Senator Mark Warner who uh you know was
talking about it he's basically like
celebrating the fact that it's a meat
grinder it's grinding down the Russian
army and of course the unstated part is
in its grinding down the people of
Ukraine as well that's not a just War
it's certainly not being waged justly
and so I do think you have to Define
them Mission and you have to hold people
account if you don't Define the mission
no one can be held accountable for
success or failure is and that's on
purpose I think yeah I'm wondering if
the lack of definition of a mission is
because they want to keep it clandestine
so that they're not overtly saying we
are involved Vladimir Putin just so you
know so they're like what we don't even
know if we're there like so that is that
was there some mystery that we're there
or what we're doing I mean yeah really
like the official seal hasn't been
stamped yet but I mean the signs are
there it's lindley's at the very least I
think but you think that's why they
haven't declared an official mission
statement because they don't want to
like push they don't want to they don't
want the accountability for what uh the
outcome is they and frankly they want
the open checkbook they want the cash to
flow and they like the meat grinder and
look these are the same people if you
look at Mark Warner not only is he the
guy celebrating this he's the guy that
introduces the restrict act yeah and
they say the restrict Act is a tick tock
ban except it doesn't ban Tick Tock it
goes after American citizens it's
completely orwellian it's worse than the
Patriot Act it is the Patriot Act for
the internet and you look at who the
neocons are they all wanted you know to
spy on American citizens but oh just to
keep them safe what has that power been
used to it's been used to impose their
will on uh not just government not just
you know the Trump campaign but on
average ordinary citizens in every layer
uh and why would we give them more power
they're essentially saying gosh if we
had all the power of the Chinese
Communist party we could keep you safe
from the Chinese Communist party that's
the restricted yeah well you know it's
interesting because one point that's
been mentioned here is the fact that our
goals have been very vaguely defined at
least on the the public facing front you
see this anytime anyone wants to run
some kind of scam or Hustle the American
people right you set a goal that's
theoretically impossible to meet or
that's very vague so with BLM blm's a
brilliant scam why well because at what
point can we say racism is over it's
ended it's gone never you'll never be
able to say that so someone's always
going to be able to profit off of that
brand similarly if you don't Define the
the goal that you have in Ukraine you
can keep throwing money at it just like
we did in Iraq just like we did in
Afghanistan there were so many different
stated goals at different times for what
had to be done over there I remember as
a kid hearing this repeatedly on the
radio operation Iraqi Freedom this is
about bringing freedom to Iraq what does
that mean right like when do we declare
Iraq a free country at what point does
the United States say all right we've
done our work and it's time to go home
we've achieved our mission after gives
you license to stay as long as you want
after we completely wipe out their
government and then leave now that
people are free now they're free they're
great yeah great things whatever you
want things are going to be awesome over
there yeah yeah good luck uh big update
on the restrict act I mean relatively
big no one signed that thing in a month
and a half looks like all that that
horrible press that came out about it
when Lindsey Graham was made a fool of
on Jesse Watters show uh everyone that
was hilarious it's like leprosy now I'm
about with that and he's like yes you
are you're a sponsor like oh I am we'll
fix that and he's still a sponsor
Lindsay is he still yeah three three
twenty seven because people are evil
dude Lindsey Graham do you know Lindsay
personally you know I've met him but I
don't really know him I don't I
certainly do have you gotten to know is
it like do you guys even have a chance
to get to know each other in Congress I
mean some of them we we definitely uh
don't spend as much time between House
and Senate you know I've gotten to know
some of the more conservative Senators
over there well you know Rand Paul Mike
Lee you know Ron Johnson Rick Scott some
of the conservative folks Tim Scott uh
folks that way in the house and mean
there's colleagues that I've gotten to
know great they're some of my best
friends period anywhere ever and I
didn't meet them until I started doing
this there's just a lot of really good
people that doesn't get enough attention
I mean frankly there's at least four or
five dozen really good people fighting
for the right things in the house that's
not enough to change everything but it
is changing things aren't people shocked
I mean they saw this first week when we
had the debate in the fight for who's
going to be speaker of the house and a
lot of Skeptics on Wells McCarthy really
going to do whatever I mean he's
fighting he's doing the stuff and I
think a lot of us said yeah I think
we're going to get there and the reality
is Republicans are stronger because of
our narrow majority because we did find
a way to work together do you think
Congress is corrupt
it's not very fun it's dysfunctional and
look you know one of the ones that I
look at is post covid we can't get a
health care committee we can't get a
dedicated committee on oversight for
healthcare uh Healthcare is almost 25 of
GDP you know when Medicaid passed in the
60s Healthcare was like six percent of
GDP then we started subsidizing it with
Medicare and Medicaid and every other
thing and now over 50 percent of the
babies born in Ohio are born on Medicaid
so you know it is a massive takeover of
the system in a lot of hospitals like 80
percent of it is health care so you go
back to you know big Pharma we're like
four and a half percent of the world's
population we take almost 40 percent of
the world's prescription drugs like why
is there this big demand for the uh
country and I think in our country we
have kind of business interests that in
a lot of ways have more influence over
the politics than the politics have over
the business interests how come there's
no committee on uh far left extremism
you know there is I mean frankly when
you look at um one of the Committees
that we fought to get created is the
committee on weaponization of government
so you look at the woken weaponized
government uh this subcommittee that
it's a part of the Judiciary Committee
but it selects you have people that
aren't even on Judiciary that became
part of this committee on weaponization
and that's what they're looking at you
look as they had my had Matt tabian
talking about the Twitter files
literally he's there testifying to this
Committee in Congress in his house
somebody from the IRS shows up at his
house now look having audits happens but
no one literally No One Believes that an
IRS agent showing up at Matt tabey's
house was a coincidence right it is a
weaponization of government and we have
a committee in in this shows like
Republicans are taking this seriously we
don't have the executive branch I know
people are frustrated say when somebody
going to jail and I think you look
forward to going through the Durham
report and saying why did Durham pull
some punches why didn't he bring in
Comey why didn't you refer anybody for
prosecution but Congress shame on us if
we don't follow through and do something
whether it's about weaponized government
in the agencies whether it's about the
weaponization of the military-industrial
complex they can't pass an audit there's
no accountability all that happens we
give them more money if you go over to
the scientific technical Elite you're
going to tell me we're going to keep
letting these guys do like fauci said to
Rand Paul I don't have to tell you how
much money I got paid for approving
these FDA patents and Drug approvals
from licenses we're not going to
restructure the National Institutes of
Health or the Centers for Disease
Control in the wake of all this stuff
are you kidding me we have to yeah when
I think of the technical weaponization
is the proprietary software of our
social media like when I I can't know if
it's tracking me I can't know if I'm
being manipulated I don't have access to
no that's a weapon that's an entirely
different subject I don't disagree with
you that is a problem but the
weaponization of government and the
collusion with big Tech I think is where
what you're saying comes into play you
know what I mean yeah it is that is very
important like that's the probably the
main focus but I feel like it's if you
want to be go after Google for
weaponizing its software don't be like
hey you banned that guy you're using it
as a weapon it's the fact that well
firstly the fact that they can ban the
guy is kind of a weaponization that they
have that Authority like uh if I give
you a giant stick you just have a giant
stick but I can start to consider that a
weapon I want to I want to make sure I
just merge these ideas for everybody
because I because you're talking about
the weaponization of big Tech but the
government was utilizing big Tech by
going to them getting a portal made to
then talk so the government is
effectively using big Tech as the shield
to say hey it's not us we're not doing
it all we're doing is making requests to
a private company and the private
company is removing public citizens and
their speech and their ideas yeah but
you look like they went after they went
after parents that showed up as school
board meetings they went after they just
defined a recent term radical
traditional Catholics I.E wow
we had uh we had the Whistleblower on
our show
rad tradcast yeah that's me so they put
these tags on it they weaponize
government thank goodness our country
was kind of alarmed in a across the
political Spectrum when the government
wanted to start spying on your bank
accounts if you got 600 of activity
they're going to report all your bank
account activity to the IRS I was really
encouraged that most everybody said whoa
wait a minute that's crazy
but they didn't hire 87 000 IRS agents I
mean that's five infantry divisions
worth of IRS agents they don't want five
extra infantry divisions of IRS agents
to go after a few billionaires and
millionaires you mentioned getting um a
committee on health care what would that
look like I mean it would look like they
owned the whole jurisdiction and part of
it is they would have a dedicated
subcommittee on oversight so if you look
at you know yeah we have an oversight
committee but if you look at Energy and
Commerce like a lot of their attention
right now is focused on energy policy
right
um but they oversee a healthy portion of
the healthcare market and so I think you
know one of the proxies I get is well
who spends the most money on lobbying in
DC well probably Healthcare right and
the health insurance companies post
Obamacare look they have like 20 net
margins the hospitals uh have to get
bigger and the patients get removed from
uh seeing their doctors right so when
you had a you know little kids they
would go to the pediatrician you could
take them in well now you can't because
you can't get in for three weeks well
the same people that are driving the
doctor to be build you know build every
you know 10 minute increments or eight
minute increments or whatever log their
time and stay loaded up on their
calendar so they can't even see anybody
um well gee guess where the kids have to
go now because they can't get in to see
the pediatrician tomorrow well they got
to go to the ER right well guess what
the ER bills out at a massively higher
rate I mean it is the most corrupt
system it's so dysfunctional and some
people are at the point where they're
just like look I don't care nationalize
it Healthcare Single Payer whatever it
can't be worse than what we have yes it
can
it can always be worse yeah people don't
understand people from all over the
world still come here it's still the
best people but it is not run well
people who talk to Michael malice
because he talks about this how people
don't understand how bad it was in the
Soviet Union nope and they think it
can't get worse and well one point about
the USSR you were talking about this a
little bit earlier with the Iron Curtain
before it fell and
how people were shocked that there was
fresh milk in the stores so when you
look at the public attitudes in the USSR
versus those in the United States
Americans were in many cases unwilling
to believe that the genocidal activity
that was reported as coming from the
USSR actually happened there because it
was just beyond our comprehension that
people could be doing that to each other
you know what people in the USSR were
unwilling to believe that we had fresh
food that there weren't shortages that
people weren't starving they thought
those were rumors they thought there's
no possible way that there was somewhere
in the world where everyone isn't
starving and actually we have fat
homeless people now so it's kind of a
problem let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really do like it word of mouth
is the best way to help and also become
a member by going to timcast.com and
clicking join us we're going to have an
uncensored members only show come coming
up for you at about 10 10 p.m and you
can even submit questions and maybe even
call into the show all right Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim IRL yesterday was
mad fun Dan is a cool dude you're both
right him F what the f they say you
we're done holding it we forward the
line
was fun Nacho Man Randy sandwich says
Ian do Simon and Garfunkel parody the
sound of Sheamus
of Sheamus
we'll work it out Ian says choose the
chickens or you'll get mobbed you was
warned Ah that's awesome yeah that's a
reference to the new video I just did
taking Tim actually not taking Tim out
of context really I just it was the
actual I mean it was out of context no I
don't think so did you do Tim's Voice or
to Tim no it's just it's actually
completely unedited clip from Tim and
animated it
when I first heard it I thought Sheamus
somehow faked I was like there's no way
I delivered that in this way that fits
his video so perfectly for those so
basically it's me saying I'll tell her
to watch it tell them yeah I wonder if
how much well I guess you don't have to
say well I'm gonna get the context there
was some violent incident that occurred
in the city and I said why would people
choose to live in these cities where
you're getting beaten by violent mobs
when you can go live out in the middle
of nowhere and get like goats and
chickens and stuff and then I did like
this little joke line about it's either
the chickens are being beaten so Sheamus
made a video watch it on freedom Tunes
because it's ridiculously funny
outdoors with the Morgan says nice job
on Beck's show today look forward to the
day you get back to West Virginia oh
yeah going back yeah he called he called
me it was fun it's good it's good yeah a
few weeks ago I was down at the blaze I
didn't meet Glenn when I was down there
but I saw you but pretty much everybody
else it was epic yeah we had a good
conversation nice what'd you guys talk
about Penny you know I basically said
that um it was it was what I said
earlier it's just rephrasing the same
quote I said I don't think the issue
with these big cities is that evil
exists is that good men do nothing I
want to see people rising to the
occasion like Daniel Penny did I want to
see people in New York City protesting
out waving signs and support peacefully
of course in support of Daniel Penny and
make sure the local government knows
that you as a resident of this city do
not like the crime and that you know
there's that woman the the victim and
witness said Daniel Penny's a hero who
saved her life
that's the kind of stuff you need people
should come out and say that
let's let's grab some more Super chats
purple says free the code Crossland
bocus 2024 cast proof for Life focus is
doing good you got a second round of
stem cells by the way he's doing really
good he's spunky
um we're gonna be we've got uh Mr bocus
pumpkin spice experience is coming soon
it's going to be our year-round pumpkin
spice coffee because I just never
understood why they made it seasonal if
everybody always wants it and likes it
and then we're doing uh this is an idea
from one of our members focus with Mr
bocus yes yeah we'll be uh I think it's
going to be our espresso roast so
context for that super chat free the
code is something I say a lot in regards
to the social media networks the large
social media networks that are acting in
the comments Google Twitter Facebook I
feel like their their source code should
be available for people yeah that was a
pretty bold move by Elon Musk to go
public here's our algorithm you can look
at it yes and give us suggestions and he
threw the gauntlet down and of course no
one has taken it up they're not gonna
they're not gonna out what's going on at
uh you know meta I will be open to like
platforms as like an Anti-Trust movement
to mandate that companies function the
United States have to have free software
code
agpl3 yeah I don't know about all of
their code but the algorithm well we'll
start with the algorithms yeah because
that's manipulating the public
all right OMG puppy says DeSantis
understands the culture warn the need to
the need to stop the Long March through
the institutions the GOP has generally
failed in this regard I'd like to sandus
if he becomes president I will be happy
um I just think we need right now you
know like
I'm imagining this big Siege vehicle you
know and Donald Trump is the the bull in
front of it he crashes through the gates
and he Rampages up the Ivory Tower and
they run fleeing from the building and
then DeSantis comes in and starts
signing the policies and the bills and
stuff that's how I view it
Henry says if DeSantis wins the primary
I can see Trump running as an
independent if that happens the
Democrats win due to a split
conservative vote
yeah it's entirely possible yeah
although they did let Donald Trump run
last time because or in 2016 because
they thought he was an easy candidate to
be I think yeah yup man were they wrong
Viking vet says this is what all these
politicians don't understand it's not
about winning we don't care to uh to win
if it's back to the old useless
Republicans
we would rather go down swing and then
bend the knee with a neocon win
I'm not I don't think DeSantis is
disruptus uh I think the dentist is
doing a lot of really really great
policy and he's really understanding
what motivates a lot of us
I just see him as um
he's not this he's a CEO oh not a CEO
you know CEO is like Trump he he I don't
know man he's been rocking it in Florida
and he's definitely not a neocon no I
agree I I like to say this but what I
mean by CEO is he he's the one running
the company getting the job done but the
CEO is the Visionary who's telling you
know like DeSantis
I think the sinus is a little more
introverted Trump there you go you can't
get much you can't get much more
extroverted than Donald Trump you cannot
I mean he just fuels energy anytime
you're in his presence he's got energy
uh you have a good time even even people
that don't want to have a good time in
Donald Trump's present fine yeah you're
actually having a good time with Donald
Trump you know desias isn't that kind of
personality I mean he's a guy that'll
you know he's he'll be kind and
everything else but like once he talks
he just didn't go back in the back and
start cranking away on another policy
yeah and just get after it and you know
I think either of them can be good uh I
know you know probably what's going to
work in terms of rallies uh is going to
be the energy behind Trump and energy
really does Drive electoral politics in
a lot of ways that's why this anus
didn't win by much of a margin when he
ran the first time but then after the
people in Florida experience the yeah
let this guy just go off and do his
thing and he's going to come back and
roll out another killer policy they're
like oh we want more of that and they
want it alone lot in Florida
all right we got a question for you from
uh there's no name it says Warren can
you touch on the SEC chairman Gary
Gensler and his attack on crypto
innovation in the U.S also about his
role as CFO for Hillary 2016 signing off
on the payment for Crossfire hurricane
get him out of office yeah we're working
to get rid of Gary Gensler I gave a
hearing where I was able to communicate
with him and say look I've planned to
fire you uh we've got a bill uh that
basically restructures the Securities
and Exchange Commission and eliminates
the chairmanship I fires Gary Gensler as
chairman uh he would still be a
commissioner and right now there are
five Commissioners originally it was
created as a commission because the
commission was supposed to do the
decision making and then they
supercharged the powers of the chairman
and Gary gensler's front-running
everybody I mean he's moving ahead of
Congress he's Republicans and Democrats
the house the Senate he's moving ahead
of Treasury he's moving ahead of cftc
and frankly it's all to impose his will
on everything uh and so there's almost
no accountability the commission either
have four Commissioners that are useless
um or you need you know and one chairman
or you go back to say look our Capital
markets are the best in the world I mean
look we got four or five percent of the
world's population 25 of the world's GDP
but we have over 50 percent of the
world's invested capital I mean why
would you mess that up but Gary Gensler
is in the process of messing it up and
you look at crypto uh he's clearly
declared war on crypto he's a henchman
for Elizabeth Warren uh and he's front
run everything for Elizabeth Warren
frankly shared Brown uh who's the
chairman of Senate banking so they're
doing nothing over there except
incentivizing him to do this the way to
rein him in is to restructure this
curious interchange Commission
right on right on
let's grab this uh next Super Chat
John McGee says trial for Trump's 34 New
York charges is set for March 25th 2024
right in the middle of primary season
and he has to be present if that's not
coordinated election interference what
is
hmm yep
you know what though
that would look great for him if he
wasn't I'm sorry I was late I was in
court because the swamp brought me in
amazing fantastic PR for him
Stevie Bibi says they will wait until he
wins the primary going into the general
and decree he is ineligible then say Dem
and third or fourth party's only on
ballot a lot of states are going to do
that I would not be surprised if New
York says New York will pass on the law
about eligibility or something
oh you think like in the state of New
York they would remove Trump from the
ballot I think a bunch of states will
try to do it but I'm not sure it matters
because any state where it's contested
you're gonna have people saying do not
remove his name I mean that's the whole
thing where they want to try to get
somebody convicted of a felony because
that makes you not a qualified elector
in Most states uh and then you can't
appear on the ballot so look if they
can't stop they're so committed to
stopping Donald Trump in any way they
can so uh you kind of got a plan how how
are they going to go after them and you
got to have a plan to stop them and this
is also why I really really like him I
know people have concerns about
electability but I'm sorry they're not
doing the same things to stop DeSantis
they're just not
because they know that they're scared of
trump they're particularly afraid of
trump that is why I like him yeah me too
Jeff Jesus Harley-Davidson teamed up
with Budweiser Harley stock is crashing
what were they thinking is that true ah
is that true oh no
hopefully that was a deal that if it's
true hopefully that was Inked ahead of
April 1st
but there are places like States
okay yeah I don't uh in the past month
they're down 13.82 percent
in the past six months they're down 31 I
don't know I don't think it has anything
to do with but it's a bit of a hit
either way yeah
I mean they're they're doing poorly but
six five six months ago that was well
before what happened with uh with Bud
Light so
maybe they're panicking and trying to
figure something else out
Beau says what do you guys think about
an election system where you can track
your own vote to ensure it's who you
voted for access it with name social
security number and current address also
a litmus test and easy safest question
like number of states
yeah the downside for that is then your
vote's not private somebody else can
know exactly how you voted as well if
they have your private information and
your Social Security number name
birthday and mother's name encrypted and
you have like a QR code that only you
can scan with your device you mean like
you had private Keys yeah public key or
when you vote it prints out a code like
a blockchain yeah it would do the same
thing where you know if it's not your
keys then it's not your coins if you had
uh not your keys not your vote uh you
actually have a different a different
system here's the problem let's say you
go to a voting uh voting station and you
go to the machine you say I'm voting for
DeSantis and then it goes here's your
your ballot has been tabulated here's
your QR code proof and you go awesome
take your phone and you scan it and it
says Trump and you go hey I voted for
DeSantis you can't sue you know why one
vote doesn't change the outcome of an
election so you'd go to court and they
would say your vote there there are so
easy where one vote does change the
outcome it would have to you you so what
happened with a lot of these uh a lot of
the votes that Trump brought forward I'm
sorry a lot of the lawsuits is when they
were like hey look we've got what we
believe is you know impropriety in terms
of the like signature verification
they'd say the amount of votes in
question would not alter the results
therefore case dismissed yes standing
was the argument and that's what made so
many people so frustrated uh between
November and January 6th and why they
wanted to show up in rally rally
peacefully protest
um and why frankly some people were so
frustrated uh to the point where they
crossed the line because they felt like
they couldn't get uh you know any kind
of hearing in court the courts were not
listening and frankly a lot of people
felt like the politicians weren't
listening uh and so I think that's why
we had the process what you'd have to do
with the QR codes is if you found that
your vote was incorrect and they
wouldn't fix it and you can't get a
lawsuit you'd have to find then a number
of people
that would equal that have evidence of
their votes being improper but then the
problem is how do you prove your
original vote was actually for the other
candidate what will end up happening is
they'll go to court and they'll argue
they did vote for Trump they're just
expressing regret now and their votes
are correct you know what happened you'd
take a picture showing that they voted
for someone else then you asked to vote
for you'd post it to social media and
you would just get banned they'd be like
ah
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Paul nyholm says China is
demanding loan payments from their belt
and Road initiative and they are
starving at third world countries by
causing them to default and drop their
own social and government services yes
that was always the goal yeah that's a
tactic economic hit man yeah yeah
exactly
that's we're gonna do the rest of Africa
as well unfortunately that's what
they're gonna do to Ukraine yeah totally
not Heisenberg says Gad sad coined woke
mind virus Elon repeated
hmm
correcting the record zeref ecliptic
ecliptico says men are learning as long
as the family courts are weaponized
against them no fault divorce is
teaching that it is not no longer worth
the risk to Wed in a family when it can
be stripped away with a simple I'm not
happy
that was Ronald Reagan uh I think Ronald
Reagan put the stake to the heart of
this country and just drove it straight
through with no fault divorce yeah yeah
not even a question unbelievably
horrible you can talk about a lot of
good things you like him for or things
that he did we're gonna I don't know
sure sure whatever but no fault divorce
was like let's let's literally just
destroy the foundation of this country
it's horrible with like functional
prenups I could imagine it like if we
get divorced all my prior money is still
mine and then I think you were saying
Sheamus there are versions of prenups
where if I initiate that divorce I
forego my ver my prenup and you can take
half of whatever so it kind of
disincentivizes the divorce yeah
basically I'm again like I'm I really am
against prenups as a concept but that's
one version of it that I think might I
don't know because what you're saying is
because then you're incentivizing a
person to stay in the marriage right so
I guess that couldn't be uh that's not
similar to other prenups but one thing
I'll mention with Reagan and no fault
divorce
this is the reality of the slippery
slope what happened was on Reagan's
first marriage according to him his
ex-wife had to make up a bunch of lies
and false accusations against him in
order to get the divorce so his thinking
was well if we have no fault divorce
people aren't going to be smeared with
false accusations because their wife
wants to leave them well this is what
always ends up happening people claim
we're going to give an outlet to
something that's already happening
because it's an ugly reality but we
can't prevent it and then that thing
ends up exploding this is how the left
always gets the social change at once
let's just let the this small handful of
people who are going to do this anyway
do this thing and then everyone ends up
doing it no fault divorce is a perfect
example let's give an outlet to
something that's already happening and
now it happens all the time all right
Guardsman norheim of the teneth first
says Tim I was watching the hill this
morning and was blown away to see one
host Brianna Joy gray claim you were
covering for neo-nazis oh yeah I think
they need to consider H and change host
again why were you watching the hills
Rising wait why were they saying you
were covering for because of that
because because of that guy who uh took
four clips of one episode and posted on
Russian social media so they claim and
because I was like how do I even know
that's legit and and they and the media
was claiming that this guy was a fan
because he took four clips from one
episode of the show that and the clips
show he wasn't even subscribed to the
show oh isn't it isn't it amazing that
uh there was no attribution to Bernie
Sanders uh when one of his uh fans
decided to shoot up a bunch of my
colleagues the other host in the show
actually brought that up and made it a
point saying like oh there's no one no
one actually oh Robbie says yeah Robbie
said well what I will say of the Hill
Rising is
you have two two things to consider here
you can watch the hill which is a
machine built on corporate dollars where
they've chosen hosts to put on a show
and these are not people who built a
show who are particular there's not
people who are particularly good at what
they do or you can come to a show like
Tim cast IRL which was built from the
ground up without any corporate
investment or backers and the show works
because we did a good job of it
the why is it that Brandon Joy gray
would say something so nonsensical about
me and I believe it was Elon Musk uh
Elon Musk Elon Musk it's because she is
not a competent media personality who
would normally rise to this position she
was someone who was put in this position
because she's on Twitter whereas why do
you come to watch this show well this
show was really small it was a YouTube
channel with no support no funding or
anything we started doing it and then
people were like hey this Show's pretty
good they started watching it the Hill's
Rising is they invested a bunch of money
shuffled around various hosts found a
person and now they have vapid opinions
that don't seem to make sense well not
surprising also this is hilarious hold
on I just gotta make a comment about
this they're claiming that you're
covering for a Neo-Nazi by saying he
wasn't one of your fans how is that
covering for him like because like that
makes him worse if he's one of your fans
and you're covering from him because the
hill Rising is fake not woke it's like
it is woke they want us to Bow and say
oh no oh geez we better adhere to the
machine's narrative because look look
what they're smearing us with the media
comes out and claims that he was a fan
because they're Liars yeah the guy
typical yeah a Belling cat oh I trust
Belling cat the the the I'm pretty sure
it was the founder who was making AI
images of trump getting arrested like
that's a a non-partisan actor they find
this profile there's no direct evidence
of it they then then I think it's like
CNN's like but he had a picture of his
birth certificate or some other nonsense
like oh yeah we all post that to our
social profiles makes no sense but maybe
it's real I don't know or care a dude
posting four clips from one show that
and you can see he's not subscribed is
not a fan they're just saying that
because they are trying to weaponize
things for political game if Brianna Joy
gray is saying that it's because she is
lying to you and because or because
she's just very very stupid yeah which
is possible it just got bought as of
tomorrow it's complete it's owned by
next star Media Group talk about
corporate conglomeration well it's funny
the whole way I should do that she's
talking about like anti-like uh the
Legacy Media saying oh we're not part of
big media and so then it was just
star Media Group let's find out
could be a startup who knows I'm just
saying like oh they're they're big they
own a lot of stuff yeah you can you can
take a bunch of money
buy a set and then say find me a host
for a show or you can look at the people
who are rising in today's ranks people
who just slowly built up a show because
they did a good job it's meritocracy
versus institutional power
uh yeah publicly next star is publicly
traded they own CW they own 75 no CW oh
so the hill Rising is this big corporate
Network yeah surprise surprise they have
those opinions but I'll tell you how it
works I'll tell you how it works they
don't go to people like Brianna Joy gray
and say say this or else you're fired
they find people who are stupid who say
stupid things and then say that's the
kind of person we should hire right so
I've seen this at all the media
companies I've worked for how is it that
you end up with someone who writes a
story that's just the most insane
garbage ever they're not forced to do it
these are people who genuinely believe
stupid things because they're not smart
yeah surprise surprise
Chris page says Sheamus back in the day
old people would plant a tree or build a
business for the children now they sell
the children or gifts or gifts of the
old for today
no well I think it's true people sell
out no it's true I mean we live in a
culture where people are so focused on
their immediate short-term gain that the
elderly actually care more about their
own Comfort or even social standing than
they do the Next Generation
all right I'm reading this one it says
uh evil zombie ham says this 20 bucks is
for Sheamus Tim pool chicken tune is
freaking hilarious I've been playing it
on repeat and laughing for the last five
minutes Tim probably won't give you the
20 so it's a good thing I'm a member of
your site that is not true I have twenty
dollars right here oh from from you to
Sheamus thanks for work thank you guys
give me super chats and say that more
often so that Tim just keeps taking
money out of his wallet and I will
remind people that like a portion that
Super Chat does go to YouTube so you're
getting a premium I'm getting a premium
so send more money and we'll bankrupt
him so so basically what happens is I
made a funny joke Sheamus took my funny
job how dare you how dare you
characterize though you made innocuous
statement and as I was listening
perfectly you're living completely
serious you were saying this is how I
really feel about the world my name is
Tim Poole and then I said this is going
to make an excellent cartoon it's really
funny how like you basically turned in
my warning you turned it into a threat
yeah like so basically I was saying like
it's a warning you live in the season
happens and then Sheamus Sheamus
animated it so it looks like I'm
threatening people yeah you guys you
guys really have to watch it please I
can't wait when he showed it to me I was
I was crying laughing it was so good I
showed him this morning he was dying
yeah and I had to I was like I went and
got my girlfriend I was like you gotta
watch this
and she was like I don't get it no I'm
totally okay yeah she was laughing too
free food for Life says just wanted to
say hi Sheamus love your work on
cartoons and your podcast but in your
podcast and Pints with Aquinas y'all
about have me converting from
protestantism yes
send me a DM Twitter they're talking
about shamer yeah they're talking about
shame so what's the premise I haven't
seen it yet I shame everybody just one
by one I just go through the whole
country I'm like shame on this guy for
this reason no I'm just sort of like
talking the issues it's just a political
podcast where I go through the events of
the day and then sometimes I'll
interview people all right let's read
this one Sean D says thank you for
representing Butler County is there any
way for Ohio to get its representation
back from the southwestern states with
illegal immigrants counted in the census
Ohio GOP were able to District out Tim
Ryan or else they were going to come for
your seat
yeah uh look this is a great question
I've got a bill that uh is basically the
fair uh representation act it basically
uh makes it so like the 14th Amendment
is clear to me that you look I don't
represent I represent American citizens
I represent no one who's not a citizen
uh if you came to the country legally I
mean I hope you have a good time glad
you came to America your representation
is at an embassy or a consulate
um you know in the downside is the way
that look Donald Trump got beaten in
this lawsuit he tried to fight it and so
that we counted citizens uh the way that
non-citizens are stealing representation
isn't just by like people trying to vote
illegally it's when you have over
representation on the Congressional Maps
um so we've talked about it quite a bit
you have like you have like five to
seven extra members of Congress in
California and with the sanctuary cities
you over sample the population in urban
areas so it creates more blue districts
specifically blue districts and it puts
more people into certain States so it
really is theft of representation and
then when you look at the way the
resources are distributed it's generally
distributed on a per capita basis it
should be distributed on a per citizen
basis or an electoral vote basis that
would be a better system and we should
decide that of our own accord but if we
can't we should amend the Constitution
to make it clear I've got a
constitutional amendment proposed it
would be great and it look Ohio would
pick up probably two seats out of that
who knows what every other state but we
know California and some of the border
states would lose representation it not
only is electoral representation still
on but I just want to make one point
really quick here the two things
conservatives say is they steal our
votes and they take welfare and the left
goes well actually because they're not
citizens they can't do either but what
happens no no well all right that was my
left impression but you're right it did
sound more like Ben Shapiro but my point
is simply to say that not only like you
said does representation become lopsided
because they're counted and they they
get extra electoral votes or more
representation in government
um when their family members are on
welfare they'll end up taking welfare
from them so they're still pulling out
of the system and there was an article
written by left wing Outlet a few years
ago after Trump got elected that said
these poor undocumented citizens uh are
too afraid to get welfare and how that
Trump's been elected it's like oh
interesting I thought that wasn't
happening
all right Chaser says Tim the coffee
shop must sell Joey's bag of donuts
yes I don't know if we can actually sell
Donuts like that but maybe we'll make a
coffee that's like you know Joey's Bag
of Donuts or whatever we are we are we
are planning on uh we've got a few
things launching K-Cups are coming in
the next couple of weeks they've got to
manufacture them but we've got uh all
the different varieties we've got a few
different uh Blends that are uh uh
Blends and roasts that are coming we've
got Mr bocus pumpkin spice experience
but then we're also going to be adding
um protein powders and other things like
that to the cast Brew Marketplace so
we're really really excited for all this
stuff I'm really excited for our MCT
protein mix for working out and we're
working with a specialist on the proper
formulation for exercise and all that
stuff so we'll get to that point we'll
get to that point but I'm really excited
to be able to launch that that's
actually a lot easier to launch
surprisingly because when it comes to
like making protein powders and
supplements I'm not gonna do any
vitamins or brain Blaster and stuff it's
gonna be like protein for exercising and
MCT for energy when you're exercising
but uh they make that stuff and then we
formulate how we want it so we want a
certain mix of MCT and protein so you're
getting fat and you're getting protein
and then we work with a specialist to
make it but they have huge batches ready
to go to formulate and mix so they can
make they can make it a lot faster with
coffee it's like we have to roast it and
make sure it's fresh and ready and all
that stuff much different much different
but uh man I'm torn between the
Appalachian nights and the and the bocus
I'm sorry the Roberto Junior I gotta try
Roberto Jr rise with Roberto again it's
so good do we have any in the house uh
no we need to get more yeah yeah just we
it goes so quickly sold out but I'm
really excited we're gonna get a whole
bunch of K-cups here so we'll have all
those ready to go sweet yeah and then um
the first order I think we're doing is
not biodegradable but we're talking
about them because we told them we
wanted biodegradable or nothing and they
said well then nothing it is and we were
like what can we do and they said do a
run with non-biodegradable and then once
we get up and running with manufacturing
biodegradable it'll switch over cool
yeah the thing is though to be honest
the biodegradable ones they're better
for the planet they don't last as long
no because they're not sealed the same
way that the the other K-Cups are yeah
so they so they're exposed to air
yep all right so if you haven't already
my friends would you kindly smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends become
a member by going to timcast.com
clicking join us because we are now
getting ready for our members only
uncensored show and we'll be taking your
calls as members uh those of you who
have joined the Discord for at least six
months or who have been uh I've been a
member for at least six months or sign
up for 25 bucks we're gonna take your
calls tonight it's gonna be a lot of fun
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast Warren you
want to shout anything out no you can
follow me online at Warren David or
Twitter at Warren Davidson or you know
on our official site davidson.house.gov
or Warren davidson.com
my name is Seamus Coughlin I make
cartoons uh on a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we've been shouting out
the cartoon I did making fun of Tim
today I think you guys will all really
enjoy it I also have a podcast called
shamer it's on Rumble we air Tuesday and
Thursday nights at 6 00 p.m sometimes on
Friday and if you want to support my
work you want to contribute to help us
to make more of the cartoons we make go
over to freedomtunes.com become a member
you will also get an extra cartoon each
week that only members have access to as
well as other behind the scenes stuff
you can follow me at Ian Crossland
anywhere on the internet that's how it's
spelled right behind me if you can't see
it there it is
i-a-n-c-r-o-s-s-l-a-n-d Warren great to
see you man and I feel like we barely
got down we we just started but I really
appreciate the uh we still have the
members only yeah the entire the
intelligence so we'll go deeper and
maybe we can do this again yeah I love
hanging out with you guys thanks for
having me tonight I want to give a
special shout out to all the mobile
gametes out there you know who you are
and uh Bernie
all right the show is not pre-recorded
I'm using your name Barony specifically
to tell you the show is not pre-recorded
um yeah it was a good one uh at
surge.com on Twitter and uh I'll be in
the chat today so see you but how would
we read super chats if the show was
pre-recorded I have no idea but this guy
was saying it and it annoys me because
we worked so hard to make it live so
come on bro all right everybody we'll
see you all over at timcast.com in just
a few minutes thanks for hanging out